Get ready, add 1 cup of water and 250 ml of soy milk and a Splash of sugar.
oh hi yo oh why is my chat not working senpai you've disappeared did I
accidentally like turn it off
they should be working
now it's fine it's fine senpai hey let's continue playing chat doko see that was
my question too where did go hold on let me try it again welcome everyone
welcome to the stream where are you
well you're just gonna be in the void forever and ever and ever from now on I
suppose oh shit hold on my theme song is on that needs to turn off sorry I'm a
little bit of a mess today I'm a little bit of a mess today so that's okay
don't worry senpai we're not back in his room we're here door right
I know control F4
control F4 click left mouse button not again we're good
oh did we kill that guy already
this filthy sink is littered with dead babies I get the meat
hello slight saber thank you for that too I stayed in the cage all day today good
job senpai but honestly sometimes I leave the cage open and you should really
take the time to touch some grass at the check the meat inventory I I've got a
shotgun shotgun shells meat meat bar key $200 dollars in the harvest blade over
here I thought the open cage was a test of my character well you can do what you
want did I ever get this toga oh wait I did cuz I made it here right I remember
now can you walk here did I turn this on yeah okay let's save here again save
game replace it with door stuck let's go watch as I fail at the point and click
part
This is why I saved
We're gonna be here a while
Haha
Keep me a second, I a drink my apple tea
I'm bankruptcy so am I böyle certain wasiks Do more damage than others this is the strongest weapon
the CIF-I the song but 백 mind
I changed the camera-
You saved the video.
I'm not a fan, honestly.
Thank you.
yeah
Why did I quit?
I don't want to tie my hits, that requires thinking.
Oh, eventually you might get tired.
Today might not be that day.
You got any shotgun ammo?
I read in like chat a while ago, and I remember this specifically, that the shotgun will be
needed to fight someone else, specifically.
What's he even hitting you with?
His aw.
What's the cleaver from the chef?
I'm pretty sure that's the weakest weapon.
Oh, we poked it at the same time! That is not fair! That is so not fair!
What the heck?
That was so rude.
It was progress. I was smashing much better than usual.
We got this. Probably.
Wow, I swear most people will probably be like, this is such an easy fight and me.
Did you see that?
Steve, would you like my autograph, Steve? Here you go, then. I'm just range rider, the cowpoke's cowpoke.
What's in here?
Looks like Tom is ahead.
You got anything here?
Is there anything in this room?
Some classic one-armed bandits.
Some out-of-town stations.
Oh, battle music. The present picture of Morris' foot sucker, McGee, in a cradle.
Hey, senpai, which one of this is you?
Which one of you is foot sucker?
Morris McGee.
I got a gumball. Can I get a gumball?
You get the gumball feel better. Can I have another one?
Gosh, is this like infinite health?
Oh, I look rough.
I'm going to do it again.
Wait, is that it?
Oh, I'm back again. I'm back to normal health.
Let's see what else is around here. This looks like batter up.
Gimme.
Thank you.
Looks like Tom is ahead.
Someone's scratched.
Is there anything I can find here?
This is therapeutic. Honestly, I have...
Yesterday, I still have the chewing gum.
Actually, the taffy thing that was from yesterday, it's gum.
It's gum.
Did you save? I'm going to save again, then.
Guess for you, senpai.
Gum.
It was all gum. Actually, the two candies with the oil wrappers were just hard candy.
I think it had a sold-off flavor.
I feel like there's more. Both teens are the same color.
There has to be more, right?
Which one won?
Bruce M holds the high score.
I feel like...
Did I hit this scratch?
Can I get this?
Oh, yes!
Can I get anything from this body? Walk over here.
Can I touch this?
Walk.
Hello. Thank you. Thank you for walking.
Someone scratched. Someone scratched.
There's nothing hidden in here. Is there?
There's a pot. Is there...?
There's nothing in here.
There's nothing.
You.
That was such a troll thing!
That was so rude!
I got this!
Oh, the body's gone!
Senpai, the body's gone!
Wait!
The p- thingy's here.
How do you avoid that?
I have meat!
I have meat on me!
Come on.
Just making sure.
I feel like I'm missing something.
Like, what is this?
Is this just a scratch?
Or is this something?
I think that's it.
There's nothing else here, right?
Okay.
Goodbye, parcel.
Bugger off!
You.
Someone must have mistaken this for the toilet.
Eww!
Can a parcel bag empty a parcel bag?
What the hell is that?
No!
I don't trust it.
Save game.
Please wipe Senpai.
Nasty restroom.
The roaches are crazed by the succulent riches contained herein.
Do I want to flush?
Olive-toned slime run down these bowls.
Obviously the products of a vegetarian with the runs.
Wait, there's something there.
This pesticides contains DDT.
Mine.
They're empty.
What's this?
No?
Did I look at the tub?
The lodge version of an ancient Roman vomitorium.
Grills.
Anything.
Do I steal this?
Someone must have mistaken this for the toilet.
Can I open that?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Go back.
Thank you.
Are those just toilet paper then?
What's this?
I got this.
Eagle.
Okay.
Am I feeling nostalgic because of the Roman vomitorium?
Not really.
Okay, now that we've got...
What do I have in my inventory?
I think it was this away.
Yeah, pesticides.
Rough up the plant.
Hopefully.
Can we kill her?
Yeah!
Sky!
Is there anything?
Wait.
An odd shaped hole raised surface.
What's this hole look like?
Bar key?
Bar key goes here?
Well, that didn't work.
Wait, there's something I could pick up?
Hold on.
A closed gate.
Open this.
I swear I thought I saw something I could pick up, though.
A cooling, refreshing fountain.
Oh, I have a cup.
I have a cup.
Well, that didn't work.
The fuck do you mean that didn't work?
Dammit, dammit, dammit!
What do you mean that didn't work?
Oh, the plant's gone.
What if I use...
Well, that didn't work.
Or...
The baseball bat!
Well, that didn't work.
Thanks.
Great!
Is there anything I can get?
No?
Well, that didn't work.
Well...
It's like I got here.
Now what?
Do I, like, look at my face?
Oh, wait.
Maybe I'll just...
I'll just use all of it, you know?
Okay.
Um...
The harvest...
Well, that didn't work.
Wait, maybe the harvest blade would work on that.
Harvest blade.
Dammit.
Dammit!
Is something in the water?
I'm trying to see.
Are we pixel hunting?
Do you see something, Senpai?
Do you see what I see?
Uh, uh, uh, uh...
What?
my shoulder. I see a baka on my right. Mods obliterate. I see a reflection.
Now for real, something right shoulder, something there. This one? Thank you for having good eyes.
Holy shit, those are good eyes.
Is it me that goes here? Secret door!
Yeah!
We're all foul smelling liquid. Can I use my cup on that one?
Well that didn't work.
Oh man.
This non-functioning power blocks.
I got him!
Is there anything in here?
I did it!
Can I hit it?
Do I use a baseball bat with it?
Well that didn't work.
Oh shit! Look at my health! Awful! Eat the sandwich boy.
Anything else around here?
I can't tell you how to do it all over here. It's always luck.
No?
Can I get the WD-40?
Cinder block anything?
It doesn't seem to be.
Do I use the bar key on it?
Well that didn't work.
Oh wait, maybe just the rope, yeah.
The rope looks sturdy enough to climb.
As you grab the rope you hear a scream quickly climb to investigate.
Ha!
Welcome to the Harvest Moon Art Gallery, sir. I'm the curator of this place. So delighted you could come.
Um, I expected to be an engaging experience.
That it will, I'm afraid. Art often forces engagement, doesn't it?
Oh yeah, it does.
Pastoral scenes, noble sculptures. These are easy on the ironed mind.
But when confronted with a work of hideous form, you're forced to deal with it, even if only to dismiss it as trash.
Sadly, the most extreme works are the hardest to dismiss.
Protesqueries and midworks of beauty are necessary.
Hold on, we're learning today.
Nevertheless, it's important that each individual determine his own sense of aesthetics.
For that reason, I give you permission to obliterate that, which forces you to linger too long in the gallery.
I'm just passing through.
If only it were that simple.
What? Walk over here. Very disturbing painting. It looks like a normal painting.
No! No! No! No! No! No! No! No! No! No! No! No! No! I have to kill him!
Is that what he's telling me? I gotta kill him? I gotta kill him?
Welcome to the harv-
Okay, I'm gonna see. Can't wait to see what passes for art in this hellhole.
It's always the dilemma, sir. What are the boundaries of art?
Only you can answer that, and only for yourself.
Lovely works, pastoral scenes, noble sculptures.
These are easy on the eye and mind, but when confronted with a work of hideous form,
you're forced to deal with it, even if only to dismiss it as trash.
Sadly, the most extreme works are the hardest to dismiss.
Protesqueries and midworks of beauty are necessary.
Oh, wait. I can go this way. You're right. I don't have to kill him.
What's the heck's this? Sickeningly offensive.
I don't see anything offensive! Senpai, do you?
Alright.
Hahaha!
Strangely, calming.
That one's a little disturbing. Looks like it was painted with fresh blood.
Ah.
This cow better not fucking attack me!
Firstly abstract.
B-19 in flight.
Great group of guys.
Heavy and intimidating.
Fuck you!
I hate art. Just kidding. I love art, but it seems to stare back at you.
Absolutely revolting.
Mercy, there was a door, but there's so much more in this art gallery!
You understand, right, Senpai? You understand, there was a door, but there...
I haven't looked at the rest of the gallery yet.
Like, you have to go through an entire exhibition before you go to the next one, right?
When you go to a museum.
Sculpture is morbid, but strangely erotic.
Huh?
Like, you understand, right?
We are art enjoyers here. Enjoyers.
Oh, we're back here now.
Now he's in my way. I don't want to kill him, though.
They don't re- They don't respawn, do they?
Okay, good.
Okay.
Strange group of guys. Are these the people who made Harvester?
The door is locked.
We have a key. We have another key.
Oh, we have a key.
I should have saved.
I should have saved. I'm gonna save now.
I thought about that as I went through the door.
Art!
What's with all these exits?
Huh? There's so many doors.
Excuse me. You can't come in right now. I just mopped the floor.
Oh, okay. Sorry about that. Um...
Hey, buddy. Give me a break, will ya? Keep up the floor.
Hey, buddy. Give me a...
Okay, uh...
Is there anything I need here?
I'm sorry. I'm sorry, sir. I'll wait until you're done.
I don't want to walk on it.
I respect... I respect the janitor.
I think it's the janitor.
What the heck are these?
A rook-shaped ashtray.
Aw, I don't want to play chess.
What's in here?
Bye.
I look like a big boss.
Give me a second.
Where the heck are all these?
I don't know.
This was the art gallery, right?
Yeah, that's the art gallery. Okay.
Oh, my gosh. There's so many things.
Well, let's go in here first.
Oh, hi.
Can I help you?
Wait! You're the... You're the lady.
This is a library, not a brothel.
You don't understand. I have reason.
I hope to believe that she was brought here.
You're the lady at the grocery store.
What?!
What do you mean, extant?
Aw, what do you want?
Since he is so highly regarded among the order,
I'm loathed to approach him on such an embarrassing matter.
Therefore, bring me the book and I'll help you.
How will I know which book?
Oh, you'll know it. He's not an avid reader.
Okay, uh...
Can I...
This is...
You don't...
I'm...
Let's see the other one.
Well...
You're a woman.
I'm not a member.
You are kept here for the services they are able to render.
Just as some jobs are beneath men,
so too can certain services only be supplied by women.
If she is here, you'll find her on the third floor,
which you'll have difficulty finding without my help.
Nah, I don't agree.
And you want something in return.
Marcy, do you know how to play chess?
I'll give you a clue as to how to get to the third floor,
but only if you'll retrieve an overdue book from one of...
How will I...
Can I...
Room filled with unread books?
Can I come in?
Can I look at stuff?
Wait, there's a chair there.
Hold on.
Now, nothing to do with the chair.
The door is locked.
Borrowed on the other side.
Yeah, save your game.
Okay.
I'll save it back in art.
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
Bum, bum, bum.
Shit.
Where's the exit again?
Ah, not that one.
Hi?
Let me see.
Oh yes, the new initiate.
Well, you're the postmaster, right?
What can I do for you?
Um, I'm looking for a girl named Stephanie.
The lodge is a traditional place young man,
and by tradition, when a young man is courting a young woman,
he wins for her a Cupid doll at the fair.
A what?
There is no fair within the lodge.
Wait, the Cupid doll, the naked baby?
However, I have seen a thing which resembles a Cupid somewhere on this floor.
Seek it out, slay it, and return here with a prize if you would seek your lady.
I'm sorry, the naked baby?
Cupid doll?
Yeah, like Cupid male, the Cupid doll, right?
What are the other fairly familiar thinkers?
Are these the actors?
Let me see.
Let's see, can you get me out a little?
Shortly, you will run into a fellow named Mr. Cain.
He has the strength of the truly insane.
You will need help to get past him.
They say that music hath charms to soothe the savage breast.
Music alone won't do the trick,
but an appreciation of music may net you something that will.
Appreciation of music?
Must you thrill rug me out to the wall?
Dolphins!
A beautiful grand piano.
Is this the music part?
Rough, hewn statue of a dolphin.
I like piano stuff.
Ah, stay in this dolphin room, what?
Is Mercy holding a comically sized crowbar, or is it the scythe?
It's the scythe!
Is the puzzle, do you, senpai, do you think the puzzle is me listening to the music a bit?
Oh, I can hear dolphins now.
Okay, I need to spot the pixel.
It ain't fine, it ain't taste filler.
This one?
You see anything, senpai?
Fines?
Do I cut it with the scythe?
Well, that didn't work.
There's something I'm supposed to see.
Damn it!
Ha ha ha!
Oh wait, there's like a swordfish thing?
Or is that a part of the dolphin, can I knock that off?
Oh wait, that's the tail, I'm so stupid!
Okay.
Nice dolphin!
Oh wait, what was that?
Poker?
Okay.
To be fair, side perspective made it look like a spike.
I thought it was a spike too, I got the poker, yeah!
Is that it, in this room?
Good, one more thing in here.
Okay, what else is in here then?
The hooked frail.
Frail.
And the vine.
On the tillers as well?
You saw it on here.
Okay.
I think you might have grabbed it already.
Oh the, I think I got the poker.
No, I got a flail.
Never mind, I got the flail!
I need to find a poker, right?
You need poking?
Epic flail!
Nobody says epic anymore, do they?
Poker?
Pok, pok, pok, pok, pok, pok, pok, pok, pok, pok, pok.
I said before it became a slang, it didn't stop.
We're bringing it back.
Let me see.
Is it off the screen where I can't see it, do you?
Some guys, do you remember when I had like the problem
where I could not see off the screen?
I can't see it.
Maybe adjust the screen a bit to see what you need to.
I can look over here, I think.
Oh no, maybe I should go.
Actually, I think Senpai's...
Is that all four pillars?
I think so.
I feel like this is the one where I got the little flail?
Okay, so this one's the one I got the flail.
Maybe it's one of the other ones?
Yeah.
It's not on the...
Dolphin, right?
You missed on the first two. Wait, what?
Huh?
I think this is so hard to find, it's a finding click.
Also, hint books.
You know, back in the day, Senpai, they sold hint books.
They sold hint books, and you have to call in
and order to get hints to continue in the game
and that's how they made a lot more money.
The pay to win, 50 cents a minute.
Yeah, the hint hotlines.
Alright, the strategy guides.
I am serious though, I don't see anything.
I called the Nintendo power hotline once. How was it?
Don't they still make strategy books, Senpai?
Anything at the bottom of the pillar?
I'm trying to click, it is beyond me.
Okay, all you gotta do is click the left piss pixel at the base of the vine.
Base? Base?
Hold on, I gotta make sure.
He's like, we're gonna be stuck here forever!
Sorry, I was joking.
Sorry, you're so mean!
I am gullible!
I am gullible, Senpai!
I'm so gullible!
I'm really gullible, okay?
Maybe we should check the inventory, I only got the flayly thingy.
Honestly, I remember when I would fall for this every time, someone would say something like,
oh, giraffe or gullible is written on the ceiling and I would look up and I'd be like, no it's not!
Is it on this screen or is it like...
You know, I only got you once, right? No, I got caught with it a lot of time and then the one that's like,
did you know that gullible rhymes with giraffe and I went, giraffe, no it doesn't!
I fell for it every time!
I fell for it every time, like a fool!
Senpai, I'm like blind as a bat!
You are gonna have to tell me exactly where it is.
Which pillar it is.
It's actually pronounced jubilee, shut the fuck up!
Just take the eyepatch off!
Oh shit, it's not there.
Play the piano, Kohai!
I don't know, I can play a little bit, you know, maybe it's in piano, piano?
Like, I'm clicking everywhere, I'm clicking everywhere.
Maybe I need to go back and then...
Uh, like, hot cross buns.
No. It's been so long since I played the harmonica, I played it in like, elementary, middle school.
Play Wonderwall!
Wait, I played that wrong.
Whatever.
I put it back, I put it away.
Is it on a chair?
Is it over there?
This one looks like funky, right?
Maybe I need to cut the strange vine off.
Well that didn't work.
Well that didn't work!
Can you play? Thanks, no!
Maybe you got all I need, thank you!
Senpai!
Thank you, I have an Australian $2 coin. Oh, thank you for the Aussie $2 coin, which equals to $1.33.
There's a $2 coin? Yeah, in Canada there's also a $2 coin, it's kind of toony.
I don't want to play chess.
These ashtrays?
Oh wait, I got a shotgun shell, thank you.
Yeah, these ones.
A toony? Yeah!
Honestly, I was going to be like, oh, when I was doing my advice screen for how much shampoo you should use, I was like, you should use...
You should use something, a dollop the size of a loonie, and then I realized, you don't have...
Wait, a lot of you don't have a loonie, so I don't know if you have what it is.
Okay, hold on, let's save here for a second.
Because I was like, I don't know if you have that.
An excellent likeness in oil, so not.
An also tasteful sofa.
First place trophy in the Cabinet Makers Union Chapter 501 Special Chess Olympics for different abled spinal injury victims.
A comfy sofa, a comfy chair, a comfy chair, a reflection of excellent likeness in oil.
An intellectual arena.
First place trophy in the first annual Parallel Pioria Monster Chess Surama in the Bake Off.
I am the chess master.
Any initiate who wishes to pass this way must do so for my dead body.
Being a civilized man, I offer my opponents a choice.
Solve my problem or fight me to the death.
Do you know how to play chess?
I sort of know how to play chess.
Yes?
In that case, make me what you may pass.
Wait, hold up.
Hold up.
Did you say make me?
Did you say made me?
Made?
Well, ten pies.
You may say move D6 to B7, move B8 to whatever.
I don't know what that means.
Okay, what am I?
I am...
Am I the white one?
If I go there, it will... this thing will jump over, right?
And if I go here, it will get over here, right?
But that's also like... I can't remember how the king moves.
I don't know how the king moves, Senpai.
The king can only move one space in any direction.
Well, if I move here, the king can move diagonally, right?
Well, I'm looking at this so far.
Look, if I go here, see, right?
This square right here, it will move diagonally, right?
I go here.
This might work.
Yeah, but you can't move your king in a space that puts him in checkmate.
Bottom right is the only option, this one.
King can't eat the horse since it's guarded by your knight.
Wait, what?
The king can't eat the knight.
Yes, they can, can't they?
That's chess!
You can get your pieces, right?
No, you're lying to me.
You're lying to me.
Look, the queen's not on the chess board, Senpai!
Koai, please, fine.
There you go.
Well, why can't he move?
Chess is a civilized game.
How sad, but it allows it to a less civilized form of conflict.
What?!
Chess!
How did I do that?
I don't know how I did that, but thanks.
Did I skip a cutscene?
I technically didn't want to hit him.
I really didn't want to hit him.
Excellent stroke.
I didn't mean to hit him!
I just don't know!
I just don't know chess that well!
I want us to win the chess game.
Okay, fine, I can load again, Senpai.
I can load again.
We can try this again.
There you go.
You can go here.
Where should I go to next, Senpai?
Do I grab this guy?
Chess is a civilized game.
How sad, but it allows it to a less civilized form of conflict.
I went the wrong way.
I can do it again!
I can do it again, Senpai.
Don't worry, I got this.
He just hit himself.
Don't worry about it.
Also, I've noticed the cutscenes are a little bit broken.
I wanted to go here, right?
And then...
You go here, right?
Senpai wanted me to go here.
Wait!
He did the same thing anyways!
It's the same thing!
What the heck?!
He just cut himself!
Okay, thanks for the key.
Alright.
Don't just say alright!
The illusion of free choice.
That's our gore.
Like, who put a key in his head?
Well, we did it, Senpai.
Let's save again.
We fought fairly.
Keep yourself safe.
I can't believe it was just the same thing.
Actually, I can't believe it.
Okay.
Hold on.
I wanted to check.
Senpai!
Kai, I have a booboo.
Can you kiss it better?
No.
Hahahaha!
Wow!
Maybe the dolphins might know something.
Dolphine.
Dolphin.
Phin, Phin, Phin, Phin!
Sometimes, chess gives...
Oh, wait.
No, it says something.
Something just gives me a splitting headache.
I mean, that was definitely a headache.
Are you sure there was a fire poker here, Senpai?
What's the key for?
I don't know.
Oh, wait.
Maybe the...
Right, the one room.
Here, right?
This is the wrong key.
Well, that didn't work.
I forgot where that room with the guy is.
Hey, buddy, give me a break, will ya?
Keep up the floor.
Yeah, yeah, I will, I will!
Sorry, I was just looking.
I'm sorry, I'm just looking around.
This is awesome.
Give me a...
Give me a look.
Mellow drama is involving the brutal murder of men
by ungrateful suffragettes.
Or popular with the wash...
Alright, alright.
As a mop, you have a side.
But he's just a working guy.
He's normal.
He's mopping there.
Mercy, are you afraid of clowns?
Not really, because Serenity...
Bestie.
Serenity is quite fond of clowns.
She finds them quite delightful.
Her words, not mine.
Can someone shut the fuck up?
Mods!
Get him out of here.
Oh, I did it!
Wait, what's that? What's that?
Mr. Kane's so material possession
since the death of his brother.
Sorry, you were after me.
Wait, is this Mr. Kane?
He has a book, right? Where's the book?
I'm trying to find his book!
Wait, I got the book?
Oh, I do have the book.
Oh shit, I'm like, super injured.
Oh, back to the library!
I'd like to be healed soon.
Where's the library?
We're hella injured, though.
So I have your book.
It took a lot out of me.
Ah, you've returned the book I see.
Thank you, young man.
Feel free to look around the library
for anything that interests you.
You told me you'd help me get to the third floor.
Ah, yes.
You'll need a special key
to present the keeping of our resident chess master.
Here is your clue.
Along with the positions of his pieces,
the chess master holds the key
to the third level.
Always in his thoughts.
That's the clue?
The best that I can give you.
I'll write it down for you
so that you won't forget.
If you don't find this key,
I'm afraid you'll never make it any further.
Good luck.
I think...
I already got it.
My bad.
Did we even need to fight Mr. Cain?
He was attacking me.
He was attacking me,
so I was kind of like,
um, okay.
Does the key work now?
I don't know.
I could have shielded.
I need to get a Cupid doll?
It's like...
It's like, uh, without helping me,
you won't get past anywhere,
and I'm like...
Okay, but I accidentally did the key.
No client meant that we need to fight him
in order to advance. I don't know.
Can I?
I'm looking...
This is a...
You don't...
I...
Well...
How...
If she...
And...
I'll give you a clue as...
How will...
Oh, you'll know it.
I can't believe we did...
the quest on Pier Accent.
Thank you for the two.
I have no idea what's absolutely going on, Kohai.
Sometimes...
Sometimes, Senpai,
if we don't know what's going on...
We...
We kind of do something...
Like...
Would you like a hint for something later?
Maybe.
You like...
You like that was a troll,
because I found it on my own.
I feel like that was a troll,
because I found the key on my own.
I don't know what the key is for.
I kind of killed him!
That was my bad.
There's something in the chestmaster room?
It could be.
I'll go check again.
I don't know what's going on.
I am so severely injured, though.
A gift from Bobby Fisher
when he got to lock his door one night.
Anything else in this grotesque head of his?
Nope.
Sorry, I kind of killed him.
Yeah, I kind of killed him, you know?
Just happened.
He was attacking me.
I had to attack back.
You know, stuff like that.
He and the ashtrays?
I already got some bullets.
What's this?
Yes, okay.
Thank you for writing it down for me.
I think the only place we didn't check was past the janitor.
I don't want to kill the janitor, though!
I really don't want to kill the janitor.
Like, for real, I don't want to kill the janitor.
I think we're going to have to spill some blood.
I'm going to have to kill him?
You think just because I'm a janitor I got no pride?
That's all I got to do all day is clean up after your rich bastards?
Take a hike before you get hurt!
Take a hike!
Not the New Yorkan.
One save.
I'm so sad.
He's just working.
Okay, wait.
Did I not type it out?
Oh, wait.
He's just...
working.
Janitor just...
What?
Alright, buddy.
You asked for it.
Asked?
What?
You have a...
You have a stink word on?
I thought you!
Was that a steeper gun?
Was that a nail gun?
Or a stapler gun?
Now he's got a moth-able over again!
Let's see.
He's got a moth-able over again.
Now he's gonna mop the lover again!
He's got a gun! Does that mean I need to use a gun?
Shepard!
Thanks for the 5, Charlie.
Oh, I thought you were experienced at this murder thing.
I want to avoid it if I can. You understand?
Alright, buddy. You act for it!
What do you mean, alright?!
What do you mean, alright?! Why did it continue on?!
Why did it continue on?!
I don't understand.
He's just doing his job!
I can't.
Oh, it's like this game's janky. Yeah, a little bit.
How old is this game? 1998?
It's from 1998.
Good night, Kohai.
Okay, good night.
Okay, well, 1996, never mind.
It's an even number. 1996, actually.
Actually.
Alright, buddy.
Wait! I forgot to equip it!
Oh, that deduction, I...
I forgot to equip it!
I forgot to get strapped!
Alright, buddy. You act for it!
Alright.
Can I get the...
Oh my gosh, I have no health left.
I have no health left.
He's just a working...
Something's on the floor?
It's his broom.
I don't think there's anything else.
Is there?
Just me...
and him.
Save in a different slot.
Oops.
No, I mean, I think there's something at your feet.
Yeah.
Like this thing?
Yeah, it's just me.
It's just me.
Is there anything else?
The door is locked, is this...?
Oh my god, is this where I have to do...?
Well, that didn't work. Well, that didn't work.
Really?
Wait! No, it worked!
What the heck?
Man!
I thought...
So that's what you all meant by clowns.
Hahaha!
I am literally living on a single pixel.
How am I going to do this, Senpai?
Senpai, how am I going to do this?
Do I backtrack to the Gumball machine? Can I do that?
I'm going to see if I can do that, too.
Give me the gum!
Wait, no, that's where I needed to go.
Where's the gum?
I don't know.
Wait, no, that's where I needed to go.
We're all out of Gumballs, but maybe there's some left?
I would try killing him with this knife.
I accidently clicked the wrong thing!
Yeah, let's...
Arm the Scythe instead. That was my bad.
It works!
Oops.
Maybe put the gun down for now.
My bad, I was a little excited.
Dessert! Now go ahead and have an ammo count.
Okay, I can't go back down. We're freaking screwed.
We're freaking screwed.
Oh my gosh, we're screwed.
Dude.
Do I go... Do I just wail?
Try a little bit of save to get the ammo back. I can do that.
Am I going to need all the ammo?
Grabbing the chainsaw, you add it to your inventory, hoping it will come in handy.
You also find a cuppy doll and something that looks like a key.
Oh, that was easier than I thought.
I literally thought...
There.
I thought I was going to die.
Here.
Don't say this cake is half-eaten.
Say this cake is splattered with brain matter.
Either way, don't eat it.
I need my help back, hello!
Then it goes more than just pop.
Over here.
Brown stains on the outside of the jackbox.
You don't want to want what's packed inside to come spraying out.
Let's play Impale the Poor, Dumb, Halfless Animal of Mondarts.
Rejector is broken, so you're unable to screen the film,
which happens to be the light, holiday, children's classic,
monkey boy goes ape shit with a chainsaw.
Soul.
A blood splattered movie screen, or are you back in the art gallery again?
Is he okay?
I asked after, like, I kill him.
Tank of happy gas.
It's plum empty.
I guess that said, huh?
Perhaps a clue as to why this birthday wasn't very happy.
Anything else in here?
It should be fine.
That was my bad.
I have a key.
Hopefully it opens the door.
Yeah.
It is a QP, like the male QP.
QP key.
Let's save in another thing.
QP.
Did you know that they make vegan mayo?
I've never tried it, but apparently they do.
Why am I sneaking like this?
Why is the flag so like this?
Flag full.
What the heck is this?
A wooden plank.
I have a staircase leading nowhere.
Non-functional prop kitchen.
Range rider lunchbox, or with feed bag accessory.
Grab a sandwich out of the lunchbox and put it away for like,
I need that, I need that now.
Uh.
The burp always makes it better.
Hammer.
Can I take the hammer?
Hammer, which craftsmen use to work their magic.
Non-functional prop.
Anything else?
No.
Wooden plank. Well, I have free planks now.
Essential theoretical equipment costumes.
A chair which has been rigged to break into pieces
during the hilarious third act.
Scene of the lodge's rap musical hit,
Mr. Smith's trip to Turkey.
Two masks hanging on the wall.
Turn that frown upside down.
It has to be a hint, right?
Top street slump circa 1890,
evocative of the time when America was free of concepts
like, what is race?
Ah!
An empty water cool.
What is this alien, the cancer?
Compliment, Terry Coffin nails.
Thanks.
Have another, dear.
Standard seat-tie fire extinguisher.
Damn it.
Wait, what did I get?
Wait, what did I get? What was that?
Lighter fluid.
Case, great. Is this?
Oh, are these cigarettes?
Anything else I need in here?
Well.
Coffin nails is a nickname for cigarettes.
Thank you.
Where are these?
Do these do anything? Did I get a hint for them yet?
Back on the stage, you can steal the flags. I can steal the flags?
I like stealing.
Well, that didn't work.
What do you mean that didn't work? Thanks.
Is it even a puzzle?
Cole hides a stealer in all these games, yes.
He takes the entire poll.
What do these do?
They're masking like a puzzle.
Unless it's one of those things, you know, Senpai?
One of those things that...
that, like, they're fake puzzles.
I don't trust this game anymore.
Is this a fake puzzle?
Like, is this a fake puzzle?
What?
What was that?
Okay.
Wait, I saw something.
The hand.
Laundry.
Red blood water swirls behind the glass.
Anything around here?
Wait.
I think the mask can was, like, streamlined.
What was the hint then?
I can't remember what the hint was.
Is there anything around here?
Am I missing something?
I swear I saw a hand.
So I could pick something up.
Was I trippin'?
I was probably trippin'.
It's like Stephanie's clothes.
These cabinet things?
Alright.
Okay.
Cut off. This cutoff valve is rusted and won't budge.
So I have something for it?
How do you do that?
Why save?
Auga!
Oh, no.
Hmm?
These both good pipe.
I French.
Thank you.
Wait.
I don't know.
I'll go back here.
I got to use
the pipe went on it.
Pipe went!
Eh?
Didn't work?
Oh what?
The Ranch didn't help much.
The valve is stuck solid.
Okay.
another pipe thing? well that didn't work. damn it! how do you mean? I just want it to
the curved pipe. our meters, skews locks, um, doors lock. okay. it might be a puzzle here.
oh! can I put the pipe here? well that didn't work.
um. oh man. well that didn't work. can I staple it? well that didn't work. wait there's a valve up there. oh!
can I put the pipe there now? damn it!
the dial is moving?
is it a staple gun? well that didn't work. uh.
uh.
oh! I was on a timer. well what was I supposed to do? it's hard to notice but there was an unfinished pipe in the middle top.
huh?
I thought I used it on the broken pipe.
I have these two right?
wait. the broken pipe. this one? well that didn't work. oh! okay. hold on. um.
well that didn't work. damn it! well that didn't work. oh man. well that didn't work.
yay!
got it! I did it!
should I save? probably save.
once I saw it actually got off I was like oh it's a really long pipe so we'll just connect the pipes.
wait why are you here?
roll! turbine screams and a high-pitched whine.
what's all this then? um. flesh nubble? well that didn't work. oh man. okay.
oh! hold on. oh man. I'm not gonna. quick quick quick. ah! the door! ah!
remains of a less fortunate initiate.
gonna save again. I can't save.
standby!
wait!
high-pitched whine.
wait! standby!
help!
what do you mean wrong order?
what do you mean?
one. two. well that didn't work.
is that better?
still going.
does that mean I lose?
never mind it's fine. wait!
oh!
rope to level three.
there anything else here senpai?
pack of nails.
door is locked from the other side. anything else here?
this is the temple of the mystery of abstinence. do not eat of the food or you will be punished. all within are hereby bound to a vow of abstinence.
of eating?
this is the temple of the mystery.
okay. door is locked. door is locked.
oh he's just eating right?
you obey well initiate. better than your brethren. they have eaten and grown stronger for it. as promised I will not punish you for your obedience. but they will.
who? wait!
bergi gone!
what the hell man?
you obey well initiate.
and some mothers complain that their children don't come to see them.
you're so good!
shocked? this is the mystery of motherly love. everyone says motherhood is fulfilling when in reality it's draining.
I see what you mean!
you don't know the half of it.
from the start, children are parasites. that's what you've got to understand. sucking the life out of you.
your very life's blood pumping from your belly through obscene pink tubes into their thieving hearts.
and even after birth, they keep leaching the life from you.
you're so good!
of course, my children are better at it than most. is that the bliss of motherhood? that's the mystery.
just what the world needs. more greedy little mouths to feed. children suck the life out of society.
they have to be protected. nurtured. everything has to be child proof. and rendered childish.
sadly, they'll suck the life out of you too. you too.
these kids are gonna attack me, are they?
wait no!
back off, kid!
back off!
I can take on children!
I can't! I can't!
well, at least the mom saved, yay!
welcome to the temple of the mystery of religion.
the mystery of religion?
the mystery is the last.
those who preach love and mercy in God's name are often those who call for the death of heathens.
do you believe in God, my son?
mercy mentioned!
wait, what should I say?
um...
wait, of course!
yes? or chance?
you are wise. his mercy annoys us all.
and where doth he dwell, the lord?
which, which lord?
which one are you... wait, are those, are those cow ball sacks?
and all of us, but this, but this might be like the opposite, right?
no, they're otters!
oops!
indeed, any other response would be blasphemous.
answer me this, if the word be with you.
does the lord bounce on a spring or frolic with the wombats?
I love wombats.
sorry.
yes, the fields of the lord arrive with wombats and he is there shepherd.
answer thus, if thou be virtuous.
does God Almighty herd them with his staff or with special imported wombat herding equipment?
there's a staff I can take?
but why would all I gotta do on the equipment?
is there a staff I can take?
did I save?
oh, I can't save.
but he says I'll take the staff, does that mean I'll get an item?
does that mean I just get the item?
oh no, I love wombats.
but then what, it means an item, right?
naturally, God, being Almighty, hath no need to import anything, his staff doth serve.
now, I ask thee one final question, which is only known to those amongst the ranks of the saved.
the saved?
is God a jar of strawberry preserves, a size 12 sneaker, a foot long hoagie, an all expense paid trip to Brazil, or a new car?
a what?
a new car?
Bugatti.
a new car, everyone wants the new car.
is there an actual answer?
we're going to Brazil?
Brazil.
you think there's an actual answer?
to Brazil sounds better.
okay, well, okay, car or Brazil?
Brazil mentioned, Brazil.
okay, fine, Brazil.
you are correct.
pass in peace, brother.
the Lord is with thee.
wait, was that a correct answer or were all of them correct answers?
I'm going to save just in case.
I was like, Brazil.
I didn't get a staff.
are you guys okay?
the rotting remains of two children.
a nicely frayed middle of honor.
that's empty.
ashes of a campfire.
oh, come on, it's locked.
well, that didn't work.
you eat the whole thing and you feel refreshed.
you fill up your chainsaw with gas.
wait, is there more?
oh, wait, there's like an exit here.
what do you want here?
I'm just passing through.
you think it's that simple, huh?
just passing through when my family was just sitting around
and look where it got them.
you killed your family?
wait, what is this?
wait, what's your...
the temple of the mystery of morality.
what?
my country paid me to kill.
and then when I came home, I was out of a job.
they expected me to stop.
cold turkey, is that what they wanted?
a paycheck today, jail sale tomorrow?
am I a criminal or an entrepreneur?
let's find out.
wait, what?
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
back off, back off, back off!
So what was the answer?
It's a nice lamb.
Welcome to the temple of the mystery of flesh, do you have a bite?
Mr. Potsdam?
The mystery is this, sometimes you have to lose some meat to get some meat.
They wouldn't let me in, until I demonstrated my worthiness.
My invitation came after I buried Karen, the one that showed initiative.
And her spinal cord was your ticket in, right?
What spinal cord?
Yes, but to be initiated into the mysteries of the harvest, I had to do one last thing.
I let them into the house, and into step-
Wait, wait, wait, what do you mean her spinal cord?
What did you do?
Sometimes you have to sacrifice meat to gain meat.
The order taught me that.
Now I am a butcher.
You should have gotten your dad to hire me on.
That way, you could have been the boss, instead of the prime cut.
Are those meat hooks?
Back up, backs, be gone meat!
Oh thank goodness.
Which direction Senpai?
Oh wait, never mind, I only have one direction.
Hello handsome, looking for a good time at a reasonable price?
Oh?
Cool, hi protectors!
But I'm also like, you know?
One?
We should be strong, should we?
They're not old, right?
Okay, you know what, hold on, let me check.
We're married!
But the game said, okay fine.
No, the only girl you have is me.
Scorn mixed with desire, that's our lot.
Such is the mystery of lust.
So often the instruments of lust, as all instruments of higher pleasure,
are condemned as frequently as they are sought after.
I'd go on about the hypocrisy of a hydrophobic society,
but I think I'd rather just kill me a man.
Please!
I'm sorry!
I didn't mean to, my bad.
Fair enough, we kill him.
Pale white and glistening.
Are you a werewolf?
So, Senpai, what do you say?
This is a test.
What?
You're not that hot, get over here!
Tuts!
You bastard!
Okay, sorry.
Oh, there's two exits!
Which one should I choose, left or right?
Left, okay.
Welcome, initiate, to the temple of the mystery of pain.
The mystery is thus, the simple manipulation of nerves may break one man,
and yet leave another unmoved.
The physiology is the same.
All nerves sing alike, yet the results differ.
The question can only be answered by paradox.
Although the body functions according to the tenets of science,
the invocation of pain is an art.
My implements are simple things, like a painter's brushes,
from which beautiful complexities spring,
different stories brought forth from different canvases,
with a different application.
What's my health at? I can't check.
I invite you now to torture this man on the table,
to explore this blessed mystery.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, no, I have a whippy thingy.
I'll have to teach you the lesson, myself.
Hold on, I got a thing.
My health is good, my health is good.
Oh man, okay.
Wait, what?
Damn it.
Oh, I don't get to do anything. What do I do then?
Okay.
It's a range mark vaccine.
Thanks.
What am I supposed to-
Am I- Do I have a choice?
Teaching pain?
I thought I could just use this.
Oh man.
Wait, maybe that's the pigeon?
Okay, well, it's not working, so...
Never mind, that's...
No?
Do I just ignore him?
Oh, it's not working anyway.
I think you're at a range. I am?
No?
Locked down a bit?
Oh!
Wait, no, get back here. Get back here.
Wait, why is it having a hard time?
Lock it. Just in case.
How do I get up more?
I attacked the rope, dude!
Get in the way!
Go around? How do I go around?
Come on!
No way! Am I stuck?
Maybe a bullet will reach him?
Sure.
Oh no.
Some pie. Some pie, I broke the game.
Some pie, I broke... No, we're fine.
Oh, cool!
Okay, bye!
I am not killing a blind person!
Well, up into the temple of the mystery of charity.
Oh, it's him again!
What mystery is there in charity, for God's sake?
The mystery is thus.
Any act of charity is an act of selfishness.
For in any charitable exchange, one must take from another,
and one is always left the poorer.
Oh, the giver is not poorer.
He receives a great feeling from giving.
A feeling?
Discouraging answer initiate.
You see, though I am needy, I do not consider myself a beggar
so much as a taker.
I require charity initiate.
Give me something.
I don't have anything?
Charity is a loathsome lie.
The only gift that keeps on giving is death.
Okay.
Well, get over here!
Wait, he's quite tough!
I didn't expect him to be tough.
This system, as part of your initiation,
will be required to execute charity.
That's how old people are disposed of to lodge,
and each member is expected to be shared.
Okay.
Julius Caesar!
Okay, it should be pretty easy.
Wait, kill Caesar.
Should I kill the old people, or Caesar?
He's got a sword.
There can only be one, Caesar?
I'm seeing more twos than ones.
You have a gun.
I didn't equip it.
I'm seeing more two than one.
Okay, well, should be pretty easy.
I'm retiring death will advance yourself.
Hold.
They're begging you for mercy.
Wait, what?
Do you grant it?
Wait, should I grant it?
No, no, wow, you are all cruel, cruel people.
They've finished their initiation.
The last is the mystery of mercy.
Mystery of mercy, that's me!
And mercy of perversion of the natural order.
Wait!
When you extend mercy to a competitor.
Extending me?
You give him a second chance to be tea.
Hold on, let me save.
Mercy of perversion.
Mercy mentioned, right?
I am the mystery!
Oh, I should kill Caesar.
Can I do it with a gun?
I accidentally killed the old man.
I'm sorry, I just, I just, I just, I, I started whaling.
I just started whaling.
You know, I just started blasting.
I'm sorry, I was too, you know, sometimes you get a little excited and then you, you
don't realize your own strength.
Oh my gosh, I'm so close to death though.
Can I move over here just a little bit?
Oh, an ancient sword.
So left or right?
Wait, down to my last thing?
Is that bad?
Man, okay.
I still have the Neo gun.
Wait, was that bad?
Should I have started over?
Should I just hit him with the side?
Got a new sword.
Yeah.
I want to save the ammo for what's coming up!
I got to kill the old people again then, dang.
Hold on, I'll stick, hold on, I'll do it again, I'll do it again Senpai.
I'll do it again.
Never mind.
He hit me!
He just hit me with one!
I'm sorry, I might have to kill the seniors.
Maybe the Neo gun on him?
Okay, it worked!
Oh man.
I can't believe that worked!
So did I finish the old people off too?
Now I have a cool sword!
Oh well.
Oh God!
What the hell?
What?
It's happening!
That was so fast!
What's happening Senpai?
Do I need a quick draw?
Oh my gosh, okay, maybe I got to do it.
Can we kill the guy on the thing?
Stay tuned for rules and there's more to come.
All right, let's go!
That's enough!
That's it!
Kill the main dude first?
I did!
Did you not see it?
Is this actually a timing like a western duel?
Stay tuned for rules and there's more to come.
All right, let's go!
Jesus!
He's so fast!
Stay tuned for rules and there's more to come.
All right, let's go!
What's your name?
How bad is my health?
Well at least I got him that time!
How did...
He tanked it!
How many?
Just leave the room?
Door is locked!
Door locked!
Cool, I can get all the way to the other room?
There's more to come.
What's your name, hungry?
Steve's a swell name.
Stay tuned for rules and there's more to come.
Jesus!
Oh my gosh, never mind!
That position is terrible!
I just get behind him.
Stay tuned for rules and there's more to come.
All right, let's go!
What's your name, hungry?
Stay tuned for rules and there's more to come.
Jesus!
He is so fast!
Seems the further the better, probably!
Well, time to get for the shotgun.
Oh no, Senpai! Oh no, Senpai! Oh no, I don't have! I don't have enough ammo!
I don't have enough ammo! Maybe we should have conserved the shells.
Senpai!
I gotta ski down to the water and hold him back for the gun.
It's the- the thingy!
Ah, fuck.
I only have four nails. Even though I have all these nails.
Am I stuck? I don't want to be stuck.
Sort or anything faster than your sight.
Well, let's see real quick.
Well, it took longer.
I didn't think it would work. Okay, hold on.
First, how many? First, how many people?
Oh, fuck.
Yeah, the static on that one kinda hurt, right, Senpai?
Okay.
I don't know how many enemies there are, Senpai.
That guy died. That guy died, so that means it was possible. I was too close.
But I was too close! That means I need four nails!
Four nails! And at least a bonk. Yeah, wait until he's actually shootable.
They have to be this far.
We did it!
Whoa!
Wait, you're the principal!
Muckety Muck?
What do you mean? You'll have to kill me to find out what he means, big guy.
Senpai.
The guide recommends shotgun for this guy!
No, we're not going back. I don't think I can melee the robot though.
We advise you to conserve the ammo. Don't blame us. I really wanted that sword.
How far back did I save, Senpai?
How far back did I save before that?
Oh my gosh.
My best bet is the sword now, huh?
Here was definitely worse than this. I healed up a little bit.
We're better! The heal!
Again.
Healed.
The sword's ready.
Welcome to the Inner Sanctum, big guy.
Within the Inner Sanctum, you will address me as Vice Muck Harrow, second in command to the Grand Muckety Muck, he of the Pheasant Buffalo Helm, the Secret Handshake, the Funny Passwords.
Only fitting, given that my role has always been that of an educator and harvest is one big classroom.
What do you mean?
You'll have to kill me to find out what he means, big guy.
Wait, why am I in here again?
Wait, why am I injured again? What happened to the vaccine?
What happened?
Steve's a swell name. My dog's name is Steve. Would you like my autograph, Steve? Here you go then.
I'm just Range Rider the Cowboy.
Welcome to the Inner Principle.
Within the Inner...
What do you mean?
You'll have to kill...
I almost did it.
It looks like I almost did it.
It's so very possible.
Okay, let's look at the animal box, okay.
Okay.
I was thinking I was...
Damn it.
Put the nails in there.
Okay.
Is there a way to open them?
No, I think they're just items that I already put in the thing.
The box here, see?
Well, that didn't work.
Nothing.
That...
I can put the nails...
No, it won't work.
Try the chainsaw then.
We can try.
I think it might be too short.
What do you think, Senpai?
Hmm.
The TV station blew up before.
That was then, and this is now.
We could use a pool stick or something.
Not happening.
Welcome to the Inner Principle.
With any...
What do you...
You'll have to kill me to fight.
Shit.
Wait, I did not quit anything yet.
I did it!
I'm a gamer!
Stephanie?
A cupidall?
Enough games.
Hit.
I don't hurt all the ones I love.
You fool!
I thought she was making me for a second.
I'm fine.
We're fine.
Wait.
The Sim?
Sam?
This is nothing more than a virtual reality designed by the harvesters to test potential members.
Having successfully completed the program, you have earned the right to become a harvester.
A harvester?
What the hell is a harvester?
Yeah, what the hell is a harvester?
The hand that grips the knife that stabs...
You're talking about people?
Killing people.
The title dropped!
Wait, the Sim is for serial killers?
You want me to become a serial killer?
Sorry, this is such a scam.
And like, games make killers?
The construct known as harvest.
What is the real world at this point?
What is the real world?
Right now, you are suspended in a sensory deprivation tank, wired to a VR tech.
If you don't join us, we will terminate your life support and you will be dead within minutes.
Those last minutes, however, will seem like a lifetime lived in harvest.
You will marry Stephanie, and die peacefully of old age.
Okay.
You're presuming a what?
Aside from you.
She is the only real person in harvest, suspended in a tank.
Jacked in just as you are.
I assume you'll want to spend time together.
Wait, she's also jacked in too?
Of course.
Having completed your ordeal, you may leave with her as you intend it and enjoy your victory.
If, on the other hand, you wish to join us, the cost of exiting the lodge is the same as the cost of entering the lodge.
A skull and spinal cord.
Oh, we...
No.
You couldn't kill me.
These harvesters, they put people through this torture to give them a taste for killing.
The way to beat them is to deny them.
To live out your life here.
With me.
You're thinking about killing me, aren't you?
Didn't you hear what he said?
I do exist.
If you kill me here, I'll die for real.
And I'll feel all the pain, all the terror, because I'm real.
Well, after all, what's a murder without pain and terror?
We will feed the pain impulses directly into our brain and then pull the plug.
You will be a murderer this time for real.
So what will it be?
Life in harvest?
Or life as a harvester?
Choose now.
Senpai!
What I choose?
Do we live in harvest and peace?
It's a few seconds, but it feels like a lifetime.
Or do we kill?
Do we kill?
Kill!
Oh, you want to become a harvester?
Okay.
Peace was never an option to become a harvester.
I think we should kill.
Everyone said kill.
Let's kill.
Okay.
For the title drop.
See if you can.
Oh, I can't say.
Can we do a scum?
Now I can do both.
Okay.
Time to kill.
You disappoint me.
Wait.
You had possibilities.
Did I choose the wrong one?
Become as twisted as you.
Wait, I chose the wrong one?
You've made your choice and succeeded in...
I chose the wrong one!
Enjoy the life you've chosen.
Such as it is.
Oh, we get to do both, right?
Look, they're all married.
Just like how...
Just like how we'll be.
Oh, we got a pipey.
An arm all right.
Oh, that's us dying.
What a waste.
This kid could have been something.
Never look back.
We got two more to plug in.
There's got to be a better way to develop the serial killer.
This is scientific.
You want us to go back to the old way?
What old way?
Good breeding.
You want us to go back to the old way?
What old way?
Good breeding.
Good...
Wow.
That's some commentary.
They're doing science.
We still die anyway.
But if we choose to live a life in harvest,
we grow old and...
Like, it feels like a lifetime,
but we only live a few seconds.
And then the other one,
we become a serial killer.
John Johns, what a name.
Oh, look at all these.
They have so many people.
Wait, Cupid?
The Cupid was all...
Was all... was an actor?
I'm sorry.
I thought it was the other hand.
Let's go.
Please help me.
I want to go back to the old way.
I want to go back...
But if we choose to live a life in harvest,
we grow old and...
We grow old and...
Please help me!
Dave, don't do this, please!
No!
No! Please! Somebody help me!
Oh, am I supposed to do it?
Sorry!
How many times are we going to do this?
There we go.
Whoa!
Wait, is that Mortal Kombat?
What's the reference to Mortal Kombat?
Wow, that was neat.
Welcome to our order, brother.
Brother.
Where are you going?
Nowhere.
Nowhere at all.
What are you doing, son?
Playing Harvester.
That thing?
I looked at it the other day.
The very thought.
Breeding serial killers.
It's disgusting.
It's cool.
You'll rot your mind playing games like that.
Don't you know people who watch violence
become violent themselves?
No.
That's bullshit, Mom.
No it isn't.
Why do you think they started cutting the violence
out of those Roadrunner cartoons?
Roadrunner cartoons.
Eww, eww, are we gonna be pooped out? Eww.
Oh, you ate the finger?
The agenda was so subtle, it was crazy.
He ate the finger.
Why did he eat the ring?
Rocks taste good.
Yubi Yubi!
Which one was the good ending, Senpai?
I don't know what you think.
It seems like it was a little longer, so I feel like that ending was like considered like the true ending.
Now, Senpai, look.
We can finally quit it!
Yay!
We're free!
Congratulations, everyone.
We have finished playing one whole game together.
How's it feel?
Hahaha.
Which ending did you like the most, Senpai?
I can't believe I actually beat the game.
The last two fights were so hard.
I feel like, I feel like, we...
The success and the ending paying off wasn't great,
but the fact that we did it together despite beating it,
despite how hard it was, was...
at least the last two bosses being how hard they were,
I feel like that itself is an accomplishment.
Hahaha.
The last ending was cool, the one where we become the harvester.
I guess that makes sense because everything was a little wacky in harvest, right?
So in the end, it turns out, and why there are some people that look the same.
Yeah.
I think winning the fights and just fighting everyone was pretty fun.
It was pretty fun.
Why were they creating serial killers, though?
We're fun, of course!
Hahaha.
It was definitely really wacky, but I feel like,
I think I love point-and-click games.
I love point-and-click games, so...
the fact that we managed to complete at least one game felt really good.
Felt pretty good, especially together.
I hope we can finish more games together as well.
How did I feel about it?
I feel like...
I can feel the age in it.
Like, the fact that when I loaded the game, it was like,
oh, don't forget to insert the second disc!
And some points were impossible to do.
Like, we're supposed to torture the man strapped to the table, right?
That was kind of impossible to go.
Alt-F4 to continue.
I can't believe I was like, this is the only time I'm ever going to do Alt-F4.
To actually continue a game.
Alright, isometric games like Shadowrun on the table, Kohai.
Isometric game, Shadowrun?
Hold on, let me go-go-go.
Oh, my.
Okay.
Shadowrun.
Run.
What is this?
Science Fantasy tabletop role-playing game.
Tabotop role-playing game?
Tabotop?
Nah, that's fine.
What was the most crazy scene for me?
It would probably be the last stream I played.
Played.
What's the word?
The last harvester stream, where they popped the baby's eye back in.
That one was like, ugh.
That's my opinion, that one was ugh.
The baby, definitely.
And like the spider coming out, I guess?
That one was kind of freaky.
No, wait, not the spider, the wasp egg.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yeah, that one.
Or was it spider?
I couldn't remember anymore.
That one was kind of like, ugh.
Babies are kind of creepy, I don't know.
I kind of like babies.
And then they reach an age where you're like, ugh.
You're no longer young and cute.
It was wasp?
Okay, yeah, that one.
That one was kind of freaky.
You feel like a serial killer now that you're jacked out?
Never stopped.
I mean what?
I'm such a kidder, Senpai.
I was always such a kidder.
Hey, Kohe, what was the last game you completely finished off stream?
Off stream.
To be honest, every single game I play have been like streaming.
There is no off stream.
There is no off stream, Senpai.
The last game I can remember playing
off stream was I the Somnium Files.
The first one, probably.
That was before I started streaming,
which was over three years ago.
So yeah, probably.
Yeah, it was probably I the Somnium Files.
I just played that thing all the way through.
And then when the sequel came out, I streamed that one too, yeah.
The next point-and-click game.
I'm not sure if I have a point-and-click game in mind right now.
Maybe Call of Cthulhu Shadow of a Comet.
Maybe it's Shadow of a Comet that I might consider.
Because I haven't played that one yet.
Was it called Shadow of a Comet?
Hold on.
Yeah, it was Shadow of the Comet.
Sorry, Shadow of the Comet is the one that I was thinking about streaming next.
Because that one, I played the second game,
Prisoner of Ice, before I did Shadow of a Comet.
And I feel like I should return to-I should play Shadow of a Comet
to just kind of tie in Prisoner of Ice before.
Yeah, I've already, but Senpais would have to play Prisoner of Ice
off-stream, because I've already played it.
That one.
So that one's probably something I'm considering.
I really like older games, so yeah.
That's probably definitely like homework.
I was expecting Dark Seed, but Call of Cthulhu is good too.
Dark Seed, huh?
Is this the art from what's-his-name?
HR, HR Geiger?
Geiger? Is this Geiger?
Yeah, I know, I know Geiger's art.
You know what?
This looks really-this looks really good, actually.
I'll put this on the list.
Dark Seed and Dark Seed 2 are terrible.
I don't care.
The artwork looks pretty good, not gonna lie.
This looks pretty good.
I think it looks pretty good.
It looks...
Even if plot-wise, it sucks.
Game-wise, well, if it sucks, it sucks, right?
But I don't know, I might just play it to look at the art, you know?
And besides, even if the game sucks,
and...
I will...
I will probably try to make it as entertaining as I can for some-wise.
Honestly, the next game, oh!
Thank you, Kendra, for...
becoming a member!
Snippin' a monster!
Um...
Actually, Senpai,
my retro tink that I've ordered is coming in soon.
So...
So I will probably...
try to play my, like...
console games.
Ha ha ha ha!
So...
Oh, it's so awful.
Today, I was, like, at home all day, right?
And then, they said,
out for delivery!
And then they said,
and then I checked, I was checking the, like, thing.
And it said,
I attempted to li-delivery, and I said,
what?
And Senpai, I have a...
a, like, a ring camera doorbell.
And I checked the time
that they said attempted delivery.
Nobody was there.
Nothing.
No-no one attempted.
No one, and I was like,
what do you mean you attempted?
No one was there!
So I was hoping I would get it in today
and start kind of experimenting a little bit.
But...
No more info other than that.
Nope, nothing else.
They always do that, right?
There was an attempted attempting.
So hopefully it comes in tomorrow instead.
Like, honestly, I hope that tomorrow
I will get it in,
and then I can start experimenting with it
and trying it out.
I have my TV, my little CRT ready
to put on my desk as well.
I'm gonna have to figure out
how to make the sound go through stream
instead of through my speakers,
my TV speakers, because then
Senpai would be hearing double audio,
and that would be bad.
But I think I can do it.
I think I can do it.
I just need to consult some of my friends
and be like, okay, here we go.
Just crank the TV and we'll listen through your mic.
Isn't that like...
I think that would hurt Senpai's ears too much.
So yeah, I'm looking forward to getting the retro sync.
But let's check what's on the schedule!
So tomorrow's my day off!
Sorry Senpai!
It's my day off, so...
I gotta do whatever I want.
Probably catch up on work.
Is it truly a day off if I have to catch up on work?
Thursday, we'll be continuing Mario RPG.
And then on Friday,
we are continuing our SMT Nocturne members only stream.
To watch the stream, you must be at a member...
the members tier for membership.
And on Saturday,
I will be playing Takoyaki Party
with my best friend, Renate Cosmical!
And that will be my entire week.
And then after that, Sunday will be my day off,
which I will probably actually take as a day off.
Unless I still have work to catch up on.
In that case, it's not truly a day off.
I wonder if Serenity would be sad if she knew you killed a clown?
Don't tell her, okay?
Oh, if it's an evil clown, she might forgive me.
Takoyaki Party is a game?
I thought you were just gonna eat Takoyaki with Serenity.
We are, unfortunately...
I would have to fly in to actually do a Takoyaki collab with her.
Because we are besties.
But unfortunately, Destiny didn't allow us to be besties together together.
But yeah.
Destiny.
I really should get back to Killer 7.
I should get back to Killer 7, but I haven't had time to...
I haven't had time to...
What do you call it?
To schedule it in yet.
Because...
I kind of just wanted to finish Harvester.
I kind of felt the mood for Mario RPG more this week.
Senpai!
Starting the plane ticket one.
Thank you, ASI.
ASI.
For the 999 Super Chat.
Thank you so much.
Don't worry, Kohai.
We'll get around to it soon.
Thank you.
Well, well, well, finish.
I want to finish...
I want to finish all the games that I play.
But there are some games where I feel like maybe it's not gonna be great for streams.
Like, I'll try it out and then not continue it after.
There might be some games like that, but I...
I usually, usually, usually strive...
Usually strive to finish games.
Usually.
If a game ends up being too hard, I'm sorry I might not be able to finish it.
That's...
That is not because I don't want to finish it.
It's just because I have...
I lack the skill level.
I don't have the dexterity to do it.
That's it.
That's me.
I'm bad at video games.
Only game you have to finish is Nocturne.
I most likely will not finish Nocturne.
Most likely not.
Because I will...
I'm...
It's not you, Senpai.
It's me.
It's literally me.
If I cannot physically beat it, that's probably...
That's...
I feel bad, but that's...
That's gonna be just...
Just one of the reasons why I drop a game is if it gets too hard.
I'm not that great of a gamer.
In fact, my gal pals are like,
You're not ready for souls like sweetie.
That's what they tell me.
It's like they're like,
You're not ready.
It's like oof.
Yeah, no.
All the love, but you're really scared.
Oh no, you all agree.
It's true though.
It's probably...
It's probably true.
I'm not quite ready for it yet.
I'm still in my...
I enjoy my pointing clicks.
I enjoy my RPG games.
It's true.
Cole High is a gamer, just not the gamer.
Yeah, I wasn't hired for my gaming skills.
Let's just say that.
Let's just say I wasn't hired for my gaming skills at all.
In fact, when I got hired in,
Strani was like,
I'm sorry sweetie,
but you have to expand
your gaming repertoire.
I don't even remember if she said sweetie or not.
She said something quite nice, but...
But...
It was definitely like a...
Oh, yeah, I'm not a gamer.
My gamerness is definitely in puzzle games
and pointing click games.
I really love those type of games.
It's super fun.
So, out and ring next time now.
No, no, no.
I'm sorry.
I think...
I think it's...
What's the word?
I'm not ready.
I'm not ready yet.
I'm sorry.
I'm still not ready.
I feel like I would not have fun
with Elden Ring at my current gamer level.
Nocturne gets pretty hard.
Yeah, I know Nocturne gets hard,
but at least Nocturne is like an RPG
and it's like strategy based
rather than I'm bad at video games based.
But, yeah, most...
You'll see...
I'll try to expand my gaming genre,
but you'll see me mostly play...
My favorite genre is point and click adventure games,
visual novels...
Not Fire Emblem, sorry.
RPGs, JRPGs.
Minecraft with Imi?
I don't have Minecraft senpai.
The only reason why I don't have Minecraft
is because I tried it out at one of my gal pals place
when I was sleeping over for Christmas
and it's really motion sticky.
Yeah, it's really motion sickness.
Wild Arms is on my list.
I want to play it on...
on PlayStation 2.
Have you ever played Chrono Trigger?
A while ago.
But I've played Chrono Trigger, yes.
Yeah, the bobbing effect gets pretty bad.
Oh!
Oh, welcome Raiders!
Welcome to the stream!
Have you considered trying Old School Resident Evil games?
Um...
I've watched some speedruns
of Resident Evil games
And I think I might actually get really dizzy from the camera changing.
You know, like how the camera changes the angles all the time?
I actually get motion sickness from watching that, but that's also a speed run, so I don't know.
I will not lie to senpai's, I do get motion sickness from even playing Sonic.
Welcome!
Welcome Mew!
Mew! Mew! Mew! Mew!
Welcome! How are you? How's the-
What were you doing? Welcome Raiders! Welcome to the stream!
My name is Mercy Modiste.
I am from Vialer's Gen 1 in Dodge.
I am the dorky yandere of my-
of my company.
Woohoo! Thank you! Thank you! Thank you!
Welcome! Welcome! Welcome in!
Honestly, honestly, we're just talking about like games that I'm planning to play, and maybe games that I might consider in the future.
I love games. I love like what's considered like classic.
Games? I guess?
A game that you've always wanted to play but never could due to your motion sickness.
Warframe.
Warframe, I think-
I think the like characters you can make are like super cool looking, but uh...
It's, it's, I-I, well, well, well, well. I like tried, I tried.
I tried so hard, and I literally threw up like maybe like five minutes into Warframe.
Like I, I like threw up, threw up.
They're making soul frame.
I don't like the soul part in that.
It's unfortunate though, yeah.
You like silly point clicks.
Would you consider Daponia?
That's only $1 right now.
I have Daponia.
I have the entire collection of Daponia.
I just stopped playing Daponia
because one of the character reminds me
of someone I really dislike.
Like you ever have that moment where you're like,
this person reminds me of someone and is bothering me.
So I was the main guy and I was like, oh,
oh this character reminds me of something.
It's bothering me.
Which fly out arms game did you wanna play?
The first one.
I wanna play the first one or the second one.
Was the first one or the second one better?
Yeah.
Not to that level.
I have the thing where I'm like, ugh, you remind me.
If you're playing a game that makes you feel that way,
do you think you'll ever throw up on stream?
I would probably throw up on stream,
but when I was on Twitch, that is a banable offense.
You can, it is against TOS to bar our stream.
So I've kind of ingrained that into my psyche.
So, I'm just like, I don't think I wanna,
I wanna, I wanna, I wanna do that.
The reason why someone did that,
they brought it into TOS that is a banable offense
to throw up on stream was because I think it was
like some fetish thing that is, that was happening
and someone was throwing up constantly for money.
Yeah.
And they were like also trying to discourage
like drinking on streams or something.
I don't know.
That one, the latter is my theory.
It's kind of my theory, but the first, the former part
is like I think someone was like throwing up
and they were like each time they get like a certain donation
or something they like threw up.
So I don't think, I don't think I wanna do that.
And I definitely, sorry, but that's not
what I'm gonna cater to.
Sorry, that's not my kink.
That's not something I wanna cater to.
Ugh.
Yeah, I'm not, I don't wanna throw up on purpose.
I don't wanna throw up on purpose
because that is very painful.
It's very, very painful.
And it just reminds me of being sick all the time
because my allergy senpai, okay.
My allergy is very severe.
And so I would, when I had my,
when I ingest eggs at all, I will throw up nonstop.
I will like keep throwing up everything.
I will start throwing up everything
to the point where I have to go to the hospital
because I won't stop throwing up, right?
So anything dealing with like barf,
I know it happens to me a lot.
It's not something I desire.
Egg, I hate eggs.
That's why I really hate eggs.
I think eggs are disgusting.
I don't like the shape of eggs.
I don't like the look of eggs and yolks.
I don't even like egg gummies
even though they don't have eggs in them.
But that's why.
And that's also, that's also why I don't like porridge
because when I was younger, my parents and the doctors
did not figure out that I had,
they didn't figure out I had an allergy.
So I was sent to the hospital a lot
and I had to stay overnight a lot.
And what they would give me was always rice porridge
or some sort of porridge.
And that just reminds me of being sick
and being in the hospital
and smelling that kind of septic hospital smell.
It just, it doesn't make me feel good.
Yeah, and they kept feeding me
because they thought it was healthy
and then I would always like eat
and then throw up.
Did you learn you had an egg allergies normally?
No, actually I learned quite late in my childhood,
meaning I was like 10, 12, maybe 13 or even 14
when I truly learned that I had an allergy to eggs.
And that was because the doctor did cross referencing
at the time.
So the doctor noticed that I was getting sick
all the time, like all the time
that I was throwing up all the time
nothing was working.
And they always were like, okay, you've been getting
quote unquote stomach flus for like your entire life.
So we're gonna see if it's gonna be an allergy
and they cross referenced things that made me sick.
And they found out the one ingredient
that was like cross was like always
in everything that I ate was eggs.
Right, so they did a little test
and it was indeed eggs.
And so they were like, okay,
so this is why ever since you were like a baby,
you were born with this allergy
ever since you were a baby,
you kept on becoming sick
and you kept on getting hospitalized.
But now that you know, you can avoid it.
So now you can live a healthier life.
So that's how I kind of ended up eating mostly vegan.
I don't consider myself like a vegan,
but I'm a vegan when, what's the word?
When really necessary.
Cause like if for example, if I go to a restaurant
and they don't have anything vegan
and the only thing on the menu that is egg free is a steak,
I will get the steak.
You know what I mean?
Something like, like something like that.
Like I can't be vegetarian, right?
The thing is that I cannot do like the micro dosing.
Um, the micro dosing is cause like even a minuscule amount
of eggs, which is why I can't even do like cross-contamination
very well is that I would also get a severe reaction
to like a very small amount of eggs.
It's, it's hard.
I also got sick a lot because some vaccines
had, had used this egg, egg whites as a carrier
as a carrier for the vaccine.
And I would have gotten sick.
I got sick at that, which I don't, I don't actually regret.
Um, I don't actually regret getting any of the vaccines
because, because of my allergy,
because of my allergy, the doctors were very nice
and they took care of me.
So I was able to recover quite well.
And well, you know, now I'm immune to like a bunch of stuff,
but, um, it, it sucks.
It sucks.
Yeah.
Admittingly it sucks when, um, when a lot of things you don't
expect has egg in it.
So example, cheese, some cheeses will have egg in it
because I make it a creamier substance.
Um, a lot of sauces, ice cream, ice cream's always,
one of the biggest ones that have culprit that has eggs.
Um, you start finding out things that have eggs in it.
Like for example, um, like there's certain paints
that I can't even touch because it contains egg white.
It's a lot of vigilance, but it's, um, it's avoidable.
It's avoidable.
It is avoidable.
It's not like, you know, it's not like my entire life is ruined
because, you know, um, you know, it's one thing.
It's something that's easily avoidable.
So example, like, you know, McDonald's, McDonald's doesn't
have, uh, there's some menu items there that don't have eggs,
right?
Or like, if I go to like, um, something, something, like,
you know, any other restaurant, they'll have something
that would be, would be easy to, um, would be easy to, uh, eat,
right?
Some of their sauces have eggs.
Well, I can avoid the sauces, right?
So for example, how bad is cross-contamination for you at
restaurants?
It's like a 50-50.
Usually the thing is that if, if like, it doesn't have eggs,
it's okay.
But like, if it's something, I'm not going to like die from
sniffing an egg.
You know what I'm saying?
I hate the smell of eggs because it's just how I protect
myself.
But like, if, for example, if you wipe down the material, if
you wipe down the counter, it should be fine.
It should be fine.
Like, if you wipe down the, if just wash the, the stuff to
make it, uh, it's fine, right?
What about sushi?
I just don't have Tamagoyaki.
I can eat sushi.
Like, if it's washed off, it's fine.
But if like they, for example, um, let's just say, um, okay,
here's an example.
Wendy's.
Wendy's is a restaurant I can barely eat at.
The only thing I think I can eat at Wendy's is like a big
potato.
The reason why is because they're kind of like egg, egg,
stuff is grilled in the same area as like the patties as
well.
So, so a lot of, and they deep fry, they're like fries in
like places where they, I think, I think they do like things
that have egg in them too.
So, it's a little bit more difficult to eat at, at Wendy's.
Severe action like block air passage, block air passage,
throwing up all the time.
Uh, my face swells up.
Yeah, kind of thing.
So, it's, it's kind of like, uh, it's kind of like, uh, that's
like one place I can't, I can't eat at because, uh, you know,
I asked the staff, I asked the staff, they're very nice.
They're usually very nice about it.
They're like, yeah, okay.
Uh, yeah, don't eat here.
And I said, okay, that's fine.
I don't have to eat here, things like that.
But, um, yeah, because I'm missing some egg proteins, I do
get more, I get sick quite easily compared to my friends and my
family also notices that because I don't eat eggs and because like
of the protein, certain proteins and eggs that eggs have, I get sick
a lot more.
So, yeah, I've learned how to avoid eggs, but sometimes mistakes.
No eggs is why her hands are so small.
Funny story, Senpai, one time.
Um, I remember, uh, someone asked me to be a hand model.
I asked me to be a hand model because they said my hands were
like pristine.
Did you accept, um, no, I didn't accept because when they asked
me, my parents were convinced that I wanted to become like a surgeon.
So they were like, no, her hands are going to get like injured and she
would no longer model kind of thing.
They were convinced that I would be like a doctor, a surgeon.
But yeah, my parents were like, no, no, no, she's not going to do that.
Well, injured, uh, it means like, you know, like I would not like if I do
like cutting and stuff that I would injure my hand and it could leave
scars and, uh, and that they didn't want to bring my hopes up or
something about it.
Did you even go to school for science?
No, this was a long time ago.
That was a long time ago.
No, they thought I was, they thought that I being a hand model meant
that I wasn't going to, excuse me, that I wasn't going to be a doctor.
That's it.
At least that's what they're, my thought, uh, brain, brain thoughts were.
My parents are like, my parents are very nice when I succeed.
When I don't succeed, I get, I get lambasted, man.
I get like, told I'm a failure.
I will mount to nothing.
But now that I have a job and they're like, oh, look at the paycheck.
They're like, okay, we support you now.
We're so happy you're here.
Yeah, money really talks.
That's how I get my love.
Although, although they were quite worried for me during COVID because
of my immunity.
They love, um, they love the fact that, uh, that I was at home because
they knew I was safe.
I know that they love me very much.
But like when they kind of perceive things as failures, it was, it was kind
of hard.
It was kind of hard.
Like for example, I remember when I said I didn't want to be a doctor.
When I said I didn't want to be a doctor, I was kicked out of my house.
I was kicked out of my house.
Like, yeah, I was kicked out of my house.
I, I was told that I, they wish I was never, I had never been born and
that they should have gotten a boy instead.
That kind of thing.
Asian parents, of course.
Well, that's getting dark.
Sorry.
Trauma dump.
I can trauma dump on you, but you can't trauma dump on me.
But they've changed their tune.
Now they've changed their tune quite a bit.
Because, uh, money speaks, money speaks.
And they kind of, honestly, they kind of gave up on me.
They kind of gave up on me.
So they kind of gave up on me.
And at a certain time they wanted me at home more because of my usefulness.
They wanted me at home more because things were getting a little bit more hard for them.
And my sister lives, like, she has her own family, right?
So I was the, I'm the only one that's like, kind of available.
And they were like, you know, they started to be like, they started to change their
minds about like, what is, what's success.
And I think they feel a bit of regret, uh, what they did to me.
But I remember last year they were like, you should go to the, you should try to get a job, sweetie.
They were very nice, uh, last year when I was having, uh, a rough time.
But, uh, once I got, once I got to VLR, they were like, woohoo!
Yeah, they need you and worry about you since they're getting old now.
Yeah, pretty much.
But like, before that it was like, oh, it's, it's always like, you know, um, it was like, you are a failure.
You shouldn't have ever been born.
I wish it was, okay.
No, I'm not going to say that one.
That one's, that one's oversharing.
That one's oversharing.
I'm going to, I'm going to shut up right there.
Okay, but yeah, but now that I have a bit of success, uh, they are very happy.
So thank you some bikes for supporting me because now I live in peace.
I live in peace.
I live in peace and I'm very happy and they're happy and they, uh, they, they have calmed down quite a bit
and their, their ideas of success has changed and now they're just like, please get a play button.
I want to see one.
You know, kind of like that, that sort of thing.
Like a lot of things change.
A lot of things change.
Yeah, things have mellowed out quite a bit.
Like if you looked at them like maybe like five years ago, you've been like, who the heck are they?
You've been like, what the heck happened?
But they have completely changed.
It was like, it's, I don't know.
It's like, uh, what do you call it?
It's like, I don't know, like something really changed within them.
I don't really know what happened.
Maybe they saw a movie, maybe, you know, maybe COVID changed something and they were like, oh,
I mean, like they were, even before COVID happened, they, they really did change quite a bit.
How long was COVID?
Oh shit.
Okay, let's just say like 10 years ago, 10 years ago, it was like, they were like completely different.
That was almost four years.
Shit.
Shit, ignore that.
Okay, let's say 10 years ago.
Yeah, 10 years ago, they would have been like completely different people.
Yeah, I think it's a lot of them are like, oh.
I guess it's like, you know, maybe like they're starting to see things in more a positive light because they're getting older.
Maybe they're getting older or something, but they're very happy.
Trust, they're very happy.
I love them, I love them to bits.
Don't get me wrong, it gets hard sometimes, but I love them to bits.
Why are we even on the subject again?
Oh yeah, money talks.
It sure took a while.
Yeah, it sure took a while.
I don't know, something happened and they were like, you know, and they, they, they've even started to like talk to my sister more because
They usually don't really talk to my sister as much, but now they're like contacting her more like getting updates from her and stuff.
They brought back memories.
All right.
My dad.
Wow.
I'm so yappy.
Oh, it ain't just crazy.
Yeah, like people change quite a bit.
Like I didn't think it would happen, but they did change quite a bit.
Hold up.
Are you sure they aren't dying?
I sure hope not.
I sure hope fucking not.
I, because I would have to take a few weeks off.
Not going to lie.
If, if don't do not, do not like, you know, invoke that.
Okay.
Like I do not want that to happen.
Just saying.
Like no jinxing.
No, no, nothing.
I do not want that to happen because I will have to like probably take a few weeks off.
Do you know if it's old age or a mix of old age and now having a job?
I don't know.
I think honestly, maybe like their mindsets just changed.
You know,
like their, their mindsets
changed.
I guess maybe they saw a movie or a documentary or something.
But like, you know, maybe it's like, you know, they, they literally had to change your heart.
It's probably just old age and missing me.
Yeah.
Things like that.
Wow.
So self, wow.
A few weeks off.
So selfish.
How unwarranted.
I feel like people will get mad, get mad about that.
I don't know.
I feel, I would feel guilty.
I would feel guilty on both ways because then like I need time to grieve, but also that
if I'm not working, I feel bad kind of thing.
Something they saw on Netflix.
Maybe it was something they saw on Netflix and was like, we don't want to turn out like that.
Like things like that.
I don't know.
I'm just like weird in the mind.
They ran a fortune cookie and had a revelation.
It could be.
I don't know.
So yeah, that's why I'm just like, oh, I don't really know.
I don't really know, but I really don't want that to happen because I love them.
I love, love, love, love, love my parents.
Like I am very close to my family.
Even if they're a little, even if they're still a little overbearing.
They became, I guess they've turned from like what, like tiger parents to like helicopter
parents instead.
One is a little bit more relieving than the other.
It's an upgrade.
They evolved into helicopters, you know, because they've always want to be a part of my life
now.
Like when I said I was going to move there, like, do you hate us?
Or when I was like, oh yeah, I was talking to my friend, talking about going to a new
neighborhood.
They're like, are we moving?
It's always like they want to always be with me, which is very, very sweet, but I also
want my privacy.
You should have said yes, no, no, I don't want to lie to them or anything or get their hopes
up for, you know, like when I moved to Japan a little bit, that was the first time I've
ever like really been away from them.
And at the time they're like, if you get a job in Japan, we'll move to Japan.
I remember that.
They're like, we'll move.
We'll find property.
We'll live somewhere close to your work.
Oh, you were in Japan?
Yeah, I lived in Japan for like three months.
For an internship, I was like kind of the first time that I wanted that I was like, okay.
Okay, I want to, I want to go somewhere.
Like I didn't really matter where I wanted to go at first.
It was France, Paris, but then they didn't have enough people for that program, for the
internship program.
So then it was changed to Korea, but then Korea wanted like, I think they were prioritizing
like computer software and I didn't major in like computer programming or anything.
So that wasn't my area of expertise.
So then I was sent to Japan because they're like, because that is like the fields of study.
They had some stuff in my field of study that was there and someone like a company in Japan
wanted me to intern there.
So I was taken to that company.
So yeah, so yeah, I was taken to that company, but in order to move there, I would have to
be like just by myself.
Yeah.
How much of a weeb were you going to Japan versus after?
I was always a weeb.
I was just a coincidence that I was like going to Japan.
I was like kind of excited, you know?
I was kind of excited for it because I was like, oh yeah, I can go to like may cafes now
and I can look at like my favorite anime merch stuff.
It was a bonus, but like originally, originally I didn't plan to go to Japan.
It was like, you know, like this program that you wanted to go into isn't available anymore.
How about here?
No.
Well, here we go.
So it just happened.
The maids must have been all over you.
They were very impressed that I had no shame.
And I did the magic spells and everything, and the dances with them.
Like everyone else is like hanging their heads long going like doki doki moe moe cute.
And I was like, oh moe moe cute.
You know, because I had no shame.
I had no shame about it.
I was like, yeah, let me, let me, let me do the magic spells and stuff.
Okay, here.
Yeah, magic, magic, whatever.
Like literally no shame.
And you know, people's first time at cafes are like, oh, they're really shy, right?
Because it's like, it's very surprising when you go in there and suddenly, you know,
they're kind of like, ah, they're kind of like, oh, welcome master.
And I'm like, ah.
So they were like, so I literally was like, oh, I don't care.
I don't care.
I'm going to do the magic spell.
I'm going to do it.
And then it's funny because the, the maid that like served me was like, do you want to be a maid?
I said, I'm sorry, but my visa does not allow me to stay that long.
And my visa doesn't allow me to work any other job.
I remember that very nicely.
I took a picture.
Did you outcringe the maid?
I probably did.
Honestly, I probably outcrenched them.
Yes.
I was very, I feel like I was also very respectful.
I didn't really, I didn't want to break any of the rules either.
So I feel like, would you have been a maid if it did let you though?
Maybe.
Maybe I would have.
But I was also worried.
I don't know that much Japanese, but it was, my Japanese was much better, much better when I was constantly talking to people.
When I was constantly talking to people, but I came back.
I came back and yeah, you have to practice it.
I probably have to practice it.
Honestly, I'm very rusty now, but the friends I've made in Japan have been a senpai.
Thank you for the two, darlin' b-sepai.
I think you're an incredibly honest and sweet girl and you definitely wear your heart on your sleeve.
Thank you for treating all of us so well.
I really, really wish you nothing but the best for you.
Thank you senpai.
It's, yeah, my, my friends in Japan have been like, what are you going to visit us again?
And I was like, I don't know.
I'm kind of, I'm a little busy now, so, so I would love to go, but I'm a little busy now.
I'm settling into my new job.
Oh, I got clocked though, I got clocked.
I got clocked.
They were like, are you a Vtuber?
I was like, please, please, please, how did you clock me so fast?
How did you clock me so fast?
And they were like, oh, it's because you've always had like a cute voice.
And I was like, I just like a popular job now.
And I'm like,
They're secretly in the chat right now.
I don't think so, because I don't think they watched that.
But I think it's because my laugh is weird and they've always said that my voice was cute.
I know, I know, it's, it's, it's, uh, some people will be like, no, no, your voice is not cute.
But when I was in Japan, they thought I was very cute.
Like I had so many people ask me if I wanted to try voice acting, if I was a professional voice actor, if I wanted to do something in entertainment.
And I was like, I've never had people say that my voice is nice before, except for when I was in Japan.
Except for when I was in Japan was the only time that people said my voice is cute.
And yeah, they were like, it was really cute.
So that's why they were like, I think that's why, I think that's why Senpai, I think, I think, I think that's why.
And they're like, you became a Vtuber, didn't you?
I think, yeah, yeah, that was, uh, I remember, I remember very well, they were like, oh my gosh, you could totally do like voice acting and stuff.
And they were telling me this and like, um, at like work and stuff.
And I was like, thank you.
And then, oh yeah, another hand store, you know the hand modeling thing?
In Japan, they were like, at my work, at my work, when I was in Japan, they were like, we need to do like a picture thing.
Your hands are very nice, please model your hands for us.
I forgot about that.
They needed to do like some product, um, some product placement and advertising something.
They were like, can you please use your hands to model?
I remember that, oh my gosh.
Wow, it connected, everything connected again.
I remember that, I remember I had to like do like flipping, flipping like papers and stuff.
Did you, I did, I did volunteer to do that because they thought, my hands look nice.
Japan seems right for you, you should go back someday.
Um, I was like very lonely.
It was very lonely.
I had a great time, but it was very lonely and I feel like I would not go there unless I was like with friends or family because there was a lot about Japan that I didn't like.
There's a lot about Japan that I didn't like that I would probably, um, and that's the only reason why I'm kind of like, I don't know.
I don't know if I would live there, but if I do, if I do like, no, it's like, well, it was kind of like, oh, if I got into like a Japanese Vtuber company, I might move, but like, my company's not Japanese, so, there's no point in moving now, right?
There's no point, there's no point in moving now.
So it's mostly like, uh, yeah, the work culture was really rough.
The otherness was really tough too.
Even though people were very nice to me, there was also that barrier where it was kind of like, um, it was kind of like, oh, you will always be like the foreign girl.
Or, and then they wouldn't invite me to like certain social events because I would be like the foreigner, right?
So like, and then at times I wouldn't understand certain, like, certain social cues that is common for them, but not to me.
So for example, I've learned in Japan, maybe means no, and no means go fuck yourself, and yes means maybe, right?
So, you know, I would follow up on like plans when people were like, oh, maybe.
Like for example, I'd be like, oh, do you want to go to like this after work or something?
And they'll be like, maybe, and I would follow up.
And some people didn't like the fact that I followed up.
So for example, I was like, oh, you said maybe, are you still free to do this thing?
And they would be like, oh, I meant no.
And that would not put me in a great position, you know?
That didn't put me in a great position.
And there were some people who really did not like me because I did not understand certain things.
Yeah.
And I would also, at work, I would also get a lot of migraines, a lot of migraines.
And I was, I felt very lonely.
So, I would sometimes like put my head on the desk because I would have a really bad migraine.
Or I had a lack of sleep because there was an issue with the dorm I was in, which was that people were partying really late into the night.
Like migraines due to what? I don't know. I just had migraines.
I've never had migraines in my life before, but I had migraines when I was in Japan.
And I would put my head on the desk and I viewed that as like, you know, blaziness and like, they would think that I was like trying to avoid work.
And being disrespectful, yeah, but like the lights were like really hard on me.
And so I just like, just put my head on my desk because I was like, okay, it's dark, dark there.
And I feel better.
Well, I think most people feel better when you have a migraine, like the dark and light hurts, right?
So like, there are things that made me feel very lonely, very, very other.
And there are things that I felt like, you know, but like the friends that I did make were very nice to me.
And I've made, I think only like, like maybe two friends at my work that were very friendly and they really liked me, right?
So those were the friends that were like, we love your hands.
We think you're like a great voice actor, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
And they would like talk to me constantly.
So those are the friends I kept in touch with, right?
So yeah, that's why I'm just like, you know, it's like, I would, I would probably be like, I would go, but I'm not sure if I would live there.
But if I had, if it's something that was like, oh, for example, I don't know, maybe if I get a lot of work in Japan for some reason, right?
If I get a lot of work in Japan for some reason, I would probably move to Japan.
But that's kind of like not likely.
So that would, that's not a thought in my head now.
So it's more like I would visit instead.
Yeah, Dark and Silent Lens was good for migraines.
And I, they got really mad at me when I turned off the radio, when I turned off the radio, the work radio, and it wasn't a good work radio.
It was like really like, like super staticky.
And they would be mad at me for adjusting it to the rights.
Like I knew which station they were on.
I just adjusted it to like the right one, or I would lower the volume a bit on the, on the radio, because it was like physically hurting, hurting me.
So yeah.
That's like something.
There were some things that I liked and some things I didn't like.
And I felt very, yeah.
Wow.
You're welcome.
Like I didn't know why they, they wanted it on static.
I really didn't understand why they wanted it on static.
So I always thought that they didn't adjust it right.
And then I just adjusted it to the right channel so it was clear.
And then they got mad at me for that.
I didn't understand why.
Or like if I would turn down the radio a little bit.
I don't know.
It was weird.
Maybe it is their, their white noise, but I don't, I never understood.
And I asked them like why.
And they're like, don't touch the radio.
And I was like, but it's, I'm adjusting it.
So it's to the right station.
Like, you know how the, the static, the static, if you're not quite on the radio,
like the, the right one, you can still hear it.
But it's like super crunchy and, and like it's bad.
Like it's crackly.
Right.
So I just adjusted it slightly to be like, hey, like get the right frequency.
Come on.
You know, like it's, it's like, it's almost there.
You can still hear what's going on, but it's really crunchy.
So I don't know why they wanted it to be like that.
But they were like, definitely like demanding me going like, do not touch the radio.
And I'm like, okay, but like this, it's really distracting.
Why can't I touch the radio?
Why is it not on the right frequency?
And so like it's, it's, it was weird.
It was weird.
So the workplace was definitely like a mixed bag.
So I had some very nice people.
They were very kind to me.
And then sometimes it was just like moments where I was just like, oh, come on.
The beginning of the audio file.
I wouldn't consider myself of audio file.
I wouldn't consider myself an audio file.
I wouldn't because it's like, I wouldn't, I wouldn't consider myself an audio file.
No, because like if you tell me what's the difference between this and this,
I would have no idea what you're talking about.
Like if you tell me this is a warm, warm sound versus a bright sound.
I wouldn't freaking understand.
You're interested in audio stuff.
Yes.
Improving my own audio stuff.
It's an, I can't do it.
How's the IEMs?
The IEMs that I ordered have not come in yet,
but I have improved my current IEMs that I use.
And I think they'll be great for, for like audio monitoring in general.
I'm using with my, with the, with the Go X, XLR.
Because, because, excuse me, because, well,
I still need something for audio monitoring.
And the one that I ordered is DSP.
I think it's DSP or is a DPS.
I don't fucking remember.
So the ones I currently own are the Choo Toos.
Yeah, DSP.
Thank you.
Are the Choo Toos because they are very cheap.
I remember someone, I remember reading someone who was like a fanatic about moon drop.
About moon drop and I was like, oh, it must be a good brand.
And then they came out, I was looking at the Choo and I was like, uh, I don't know.
But then I was looking at like IEMs that were like, what do you call it?
Like they had like the, the cables.
Yeah.
And they announced the Choo Too.
And so I pre-ordered it and I pre-ordered it for like $220 or something.
And I was like, whatever, it's from a brand.
I know a few people, like I actually know more than one person, which is surprising.
Um, there are like big fans of this brand, Moon Drop.
So I was like, okay.
Um, okay, sure.
Uh, so I pre-ordered that one because it was, it's cheap as shit.
It's cheap as shit, right?
Like how can I say no to $20?
Like $20 Canadian too.
So I was like, oh, that's really affordable.
So I got that.
I got that.
And, you know, it was all right.
It was a lot.
All right.
Like it's, it's, it's cheap.
And I, I was like, um, I'm the type of person who I have to really decide on what to get.
Otherwise, um, I don't want to waste my time and my money, if that makes sense.
Um, so that's why I pick myself carefully.
So I can't really experiment Senpai.
I can't really experiment, um, with like, like if someone asked me, oh, what, what,
what have you noticed with, um, what was this question on Twitter?
Sorry, Senpai.
So I'm using you as a sample, as a sample, as a, uh, example.
But be, uh, like, what's your experience with audio interfaces?
And I'm like, I've only owned one audio interface kind of thing.
Like I'm not, I'm not that person.
I've only owned two, actually two audio interfaces, but, um, I don't have the funds to experiment,
I guess.
I don't have the funds to experiment, um, with, with like audio equipment.
So I have to choose very carefully.
I tend to choose, uh, choose like things on cheaper end that are very reliable.
For example, my microphone is an AT2020.
Very reliable, pretty freaking cheap.
Uh, if you get it on sale, it can be even just like 90 bucks.
I don't think I got it on sale though, because I had to replace an older USB microphone that I owned.
Uh, so I tend to choose things that are reliable.
So that's why I'm just like, if you were like, oh, are you into IEMs?
I'm just like, I will only, like, this is probably going to be the only IEM I ever own.
Unless, like, given the opportunity, maybe I might own three, max three.
So I just wanted to get something that was like reliable, because people were like, oh, you know, if you use IEMs, it's going to, it's going to change the way you, you listen to music for the rest of your life.
And like, you never hear music like this before.
So I was like, oh, okay, well, maybe I'll give it a shot.
And people were like, oh, IEMs are great for monitoring sound and like, you know, like doing studio stuff.
And I said, oh, okay, I'll give it a shot since I only exclusively basically use these open back heads, headphones that aren't very good for monitoring, right?
So I was like, okay, and then, you know, I saw the chew twos and they were like, oh, well, things are replaceable.
If the cable breaks, you can replace them.
There's, you can swap cables.
The filter can, can be changed and removed.
And I was like, oh, well, that sounds nice if it's like fixable.
Okay.
The only one I would probably want next would probably be the blessing three because everyone in their moms, everyone in their mom and the grandmas and the grandpas have said that like the blessing three is like really good.
But I cannot, I cannot just like spending four over 400, like nearly $500 for her IEMs, you know, that's, that's going to be like that.
That's so much, that's so much.
That's like the, the cost of, that's the cost of the go XLR, you know, that's a lot of money.
And like, I've read reviews saying like, oh, the, the cable's not great.
And the case is not great.
And I'm just like, oh, no, I can't justify it.
No, I can't justify it.
Like, I can't even justify like certain things, right?
There's certain things I can't just justify.
For that much is better.
I'll be great.
That's what I was thinking too.
I was like, for like over five, I knew like $500.
Why isn't the wire good?
And why isn't the case good?
You know, the ones that I bought though are called open audio, which pro, but this one's the DSP version.
I've honestly only got it because it was pink.
I honestly only got it because it was pink.
And it looked cute.
And I was like, oh, I need more cuteness in my life.
You know?
I just, I just don't know.
What do you mean next you should get the PS Vita version?
What do you mean PS Vita version?
I have a Vita.
Like it's, it's, it's a lot of money.
You know, it's a lot of money.
And I'm thinking I'm spending quite a bit.
Like, even though Senpai gifted me this, I'm still thinking like, oh, this is quite, quite, quite a bit.
Um, for, for, for, you know, like audio stuff.
Because it's like, what, like, what was it?
130?
Yeah, 130 Canadian.
So I was like, oh, well, that's not terrible.
But I thank you for spoiling me.
Oh shit.
I talked for like over two hours.
Wow.
I'm such a yapper.
God, I need to shut up.
I always, I always feel bad for like yapping all the time.
It was, it was, uh, like in IRL.
Let's say IRL.
Even though I know this is real and you are all real.
Um, but like, I've been told a lot of my entire life that like, oh, I'm talking too much.
I should shut up, you know?
You know what I mean?
I've, now that nobody's stopping me, I feel that sense of guilt, I guess.
I feel like I, I've taken your time, your time by over talking.
And that's, that's still in me, you know, that's still in me.
That's still in me because I'm so very used to people being like, stop or, uh, you know, wrap it up.
So that's why I always apologize.
I'm like, oh shit, I didn't realize I talked so damn much.
So that's why I was like, oh, oh, I feel bad.
I feel bad because I don't know.
Have you?
Senpai!
Thank you for the super chat.
Woo, thank you D-Man.
I'd rather hear you yapping to sleep TVH.
So silly.
But I, I don't know.
I feel like it's a, it's a, it's a tism thing.
It's a tism thing where people have been used to being like telling, telling you that you're like yapping too much or you're talking too much or you're over explaining things, you know?
And now that, you know, the plug is not there, all social cues gone.
The, the, the plug of like someone telling you, wrap it up or like, please, uh, please keep it short or, uh, I have to go now kind of thing is that social cues out the window.
It's gone.
So, yeah, I'm just like, oh, but it's still in me because, you know, I've learned to read a bit of body language to tell, to tell when someone is like done with me and I need to wrap it up.
But now, but I'm talking to step by, I don't have those visual cues, so I just keep talking.
So I just keep talking and then I'm like, oh, thank God, chat doesn't have a body.
It's, it's true.
It's true.
Like you, it's, it's so interesting now that, now that like, you know, the limiter is off.
You don't have any social cues to like, would you learn how to like get, get them, right?
Yeah.
Cole, hi, are you acoustic?
It was just, we need a Mercy's at that sooner.
An unlimited all you can.
Yeah.
I don't think I have stopped.
Yeah, I think I could get for six hours.
I can't believe Mercy is artistic.
Please forgive me.
I'm a little acoustic.
Good.
Only two more hours.
Just like mummy.
I think that's what I think she told the story that like the reason one of the biggest reasons
why I got in was because it was like, oh, she had a section in the audition that said,
oh, what would you like us?
Is there anything else to you?
You, you would like us to know.
And I said, I, I am on the spectrum.
And that's like one of the reasons, one of the main reasons why.
She go, yeah, I didn't think, I didn't think, I didn't think it was much, right?
I didn't think I was like, oh, maybe they should know.
Oh, and then I also put in, oh, by the way, I live with my parents.
I'm not joking.
That's what I really did.
I was like, oh, and I live with my parents.
It was, it was definitely like a, oh, well, it was, I was, I definitely took off.
This is what I did different this time for this audition was I kind of just through almost,
almost through professionalism out the window.
I almost threw it out of the window.
Almost.
I put a little ha ha in between.
I feel like it depends on like, I change my tone based off of who I'm talking to.
So if someone, like if I, if I find a company a little, a little very like, you know, no,
very, very professional, I will also mirror them, right?
I will mirror them.
And, you know, I was watching scrawny streams talking about like what you want in a company and stuff.
And, you know, a lot of the things that she valued, I valued a lot.
And it just like clicked.
It just clicked.
And I was like, I want to join this company.
So that's why I always say like, you know, her, her like dreams resonated with me.
And I really did.
Cause like, I just clicked.
I was like, I agree.
I agree.
The entire time I was like, I agree.
Like, and so I felt that there was a bit of like, you know, the, the professional, professional,
professionalism, professionalism, that the extreme professionalism that wasn't there.
So I felt like I could be like, kind of like, you know, like business casual.
I thought that makes sense.
It felt like destiny.
Like honestly, it did feel like destiny because everything lined up correctly.
Was there a time where you were like, I don't agree in the interview?
Oh.
Um, I didn't really get an interview.
I don't know about the other girls, but personally I was late.
I was late.
So I, I thought I didn't get in.
I thought I didn't get in.
Right.
I did.
I thought I failed even, even though the alert watched my audition video.
Quite a bit.
I was like, oh man.
Oh, well, um, you were like, no, no, they were, they contact, they contacted me late.
So I, I really thought I didn't get in.
And, but they watched my video quite a bit.
Like my audition video was like, watched so much.
And at the time I was like, oh, well, they must have been interested in me.
So I'm going to send a follow-up email just to be like, hey, um, hey, what's, what's, uh,
what, hey, I noticed you watched me quite a bit.
I was wondering, uh, where I can improve so I can get a, um, so I can get to the next step of the audition next time I apply.
I wouldn't have done that if I, uh, if they didn't watch me that much.
Right.
Like if I only got, if I got zero views on like my, my audition video, I'd be like, no, I'm not going to follow up.
But like it was quite a bit, quite a, quite a, quite a large number of views.
And so I, you know, I sent it off.
And then I was like, oh, okay, well, time to move on.
And, uh, and I got an email back like a few days later saying, oh my gosh, sorry, uh,
for, we got really busy.
Uh, do you have time for an interview?
And then I screamed when I got the email.
I screamed when I got the email.
And then when I did, I went in for the interview.
It wasn't really an interview.
It was more like a, sorry, we're late.
Hey, sorry, we're late.
Here's the rundown.
And, uh,
and I was like, oh yeah.
But I was like, I screamed so hard, I was coughing the entire time.
I was coughing the entire time.
I was like, oh, it was like, it was like that the entire time I was like, oh my gosh.
Cause I screamed so hard when I got the email.
And then I like instantly, they're like, here, uh, here's the details for the interview.
Uh, let us know what time when you're ready.
And I'm like, I'm here.
So I, I let up like the biggest scream ever cause I didn't think that would work.
And they're like, yeah, we were going to contact you.
Um, unfortunately we got really busy.
Uh, sorry, we're late.
Uh, here's, here's like, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Here's the contract.
Okay.
Sorry.
Sorry about that.
That's the way to do it.
Hello Lauren.
But yeah, that's, that's what, that's what happened.
And then I got in and I'm a little nervous.
I was a little nervous because I, I was, I was really nervous because you know, like,
I was the late comer.
I was, I was the, I, I believe I was the last one to join.
Yeah.
I believe I was the, the last one to join, uh, the, the indulge.
So I was the last to join everyone.
So I was, I was really nervous cause, uh, by that time it was quite, quite a bit past
the date and they're like, oh my gosh, we're, we're so sorry.
Uh, we didn't contact you.
We were so busy.
Blah, blah, blah.
Yeah.
I'm glad we have you as our Kohai.
Kohai.
Thank you.
Kisato daijuu for the 20.
For the 20 super.
Also same as the last one to join.
Yeah.
It's kind of, it's kind of wild, right?
But it was like past the, the time that was estimated.
It was like, oh, you know, uh, here's the time that, you know, you'll expect emails.
And I just thought, oh, bye.
Oh, wow.
Shit.
Bye.
I thought, I thought I didn't get in.
So yeah, I ended up getting in and I was really happy.
And Strani said that she loved my audition video because she thought it was so funny.
She thought it was so funny and that it was really entertaining and made her laugh a lot.
And so I was like, oh, yay.
I don't mind though.
I don't mind.
I'm here now.
It doesn't matter.
I'm going to work hard so that Strani can be proud of me.
So I can be a good daughter.
Honestly, you are a wonderful VTuber.
Thank you.
It is years of experience.
I don't talk about my past life, but I will talk about my past life experiences.
So that it kind of gives you a timeline of how long I've been doing this for.
So I feel happy that maybe you don't have to hide your past life, but it provides context for me.
You know?
So, yeah.
So yeah, those who know, you know, but let's keep it a secret between you and me.
I'm different with your past experience than now.
It's the same with Lude on the side.
I have more help because I was a one, you know, I was only like one person.
I was only one person.
I was only one person and a lot of it was really hard because I wouldn't know a lot of things, right?
And I don't have now, now that I'm here, people, people are more willing to talk to me.
So that's something that's very different.
I don't feel like, you know, I have to...
I don't have to force myself to do everything, you know?
And like, I don't have to force myself to do everything and I don't have to try as hard, you know?
Yeah.
And I guess like, this is like a mixed bag, but like, I don't have to feel uncomfortable, I guess.
Because like now I have people to help me with things.
Because, you know, it would be uncomfortable if I have to like address something in the community
and be like, okay, I have to talk about this because this has been bothering me,
but now I can just go to management and say, this has been bothering me, can you deal with it?
That's like, that's like, I feel like that's something that, you know, I didn't have, right?
I didn't have.
And I guess like, the things that are different is that it's just that I have help now.
I have help now and that's really, really great because, you know, being a one-man show the entire time is really exhausting.
And I'm very grateful for like the hard work that I did, but you know, it was great to just have, you know, knowing that people are there for you.
Yeah.
I admit I am the most acel.
I admit I am the most acel because I am the most inexperienced.
But, but it's definitely kind of like a, it's not something I don't want to do.
Does that make sense?
Like people, I know that, okay, maybe not talking about this.
No, I'm not going to talk about it.
Some people might think that, that, that this isn't what I wanted.
And in reality, it is what I wanted.
Like, I spent time experimenting with, with, like not say for work stuff.
And I, I had to make sure my, I myself was like, do I want to do not say for work content?
And so I, I, I was, I was like, okay, I have to have to know now.
Otherwise, I'm not going to audition.
And it's going to be really, really, really rough if I, if this is not what something I want to do.
And so I started streaming on Fansley to make sure that it's something I want to do.
And when I started streaming on Fansley, it was the most, most fun I've ever had ever in VTubing.
Like ever.
It was the most fun.
I felt so free.
I had so much fun.
It was, it was liberating.
It was liberating.
And I honestly was like, this is so much fun.
All I really did was play Aerogay, but it was the most fun I've ever had, like ever.
And then I started voice of doing the voices in the Aerogay.
And then I had lots of fun doing that.
And I did this continuously for like months.
Okay.
I did this continuously for months.
And then I thought, and then I, that was when I realized, yeah, I want to do this.
Yeah, I want to do this.
So that's why I applied.
Otherwise I wouldn't have applied at all if I wasn't comfortable with like not safer work stuff.
But like admittingly, most of my life, I was like most of my VTubing career as an indie has been, has been, what do you call it?
Has been very say so.
So I guess that's how it is.
I'm also a little bit, I'm also a little bit, as my senpai call it, pawn.
So there's a lot of things I don't know.
So there's some things I don't understand or I don't, I just, I'm just very naive about it, right?
So I was just like, oh.
So it's one of those things where it's just like, I don't get it.
Like, you know, like sometimes, you know, whoosh, the joke goes over my head.
Or, oh, that was supposed to be like a very saucy thing.
Whoops, I didn't get it.
Yeah, it really is.
It was just like, it's just me being kind of like an, an airhead, right?
How do you feel when VR lore gets a second gen and you're officially a senpai?
That's a year from now.
I don't want to think about that, that's a year from now.
At least a year from now, so.
Yeah, so a part of me is still pure, but I'm solely getting corrupted.
I'm gonna take my time though, so.
So I'm still gonna take my time.
Sorry about that, like, it's a year from now, I don't want to really think about it.
I'm still adjusting to my role.
So yeah, it is literally probably a corruption arc for me.
Don't get me wrong though, I am not very pure because I do play, like, Aerogay.
And I do, like, read Dojins.
And I do read, like, you know, saucy, saucy, mong, mangols, manga, right?
Um, so I'm not, like, fully innocent and I will, I will, like, have my fun with it, but I don't really, uh...
I don't really, what's the word?
I don't, there's still a lot of stuff that I'm just, like, oh?
I'm only, yeah, it's, like, intellectual, in the sheets, zero experience in the sheets.
You wanna leak any numbers?
Um...
Stay by me side M is the title of my favorite one.
Academic DJ.
It's true though, it's true, I am an academic DJ because I did study and I did write a paper on...
Oh shit, I should have been, I should have been, like, censoring myself.
We'll start now, on f*** time.
Stay by me side B, I think, or is it side M?
I don't remember, whatever.
Stay by me side B, or side M, I don't remember.
It's a very cute one, it's a very cute one.
I like, it's, like, an alternate, there's, like, a main storyline, and then I like the alternate storyline.
That was my, my favorite because I thought it was very sweet.
Okay, yeah, I like vanilla, sorry.
It was a happy ending, right, you know?
Like, marriage!
Marriage!
And I'm like, oh, that's so sweet!
I didn't like the, the main one because I was like, oh, so it's not for me.
I was like, oh, they're married and they're having their, like, you know...
It's, it's, it's cute!
I like those, I like the cute stuff, I also really like the very violent stuff.
Not on real people, but like the violent stuff, I'm just like, huh, huh, huh, huh.
A lot of great story, a lot of great horror story.
That was something horrible, no!
What?
Like, there's like one that I really like, um, it's about dolls?
Like, making people into dolls, and that's all I'm gonna tell you.
I really like that one for the story.
There's another one that I really liked, it's a part of a fairy tale series,
that it's kind of like very, very, uh, creepy, creepy type of folklore
with a little bit of, uh, arrow in it, right?
For the start, no, I'm serious, it was for the story!
Sorry!
Uh...
It was good, it was like really good.
Like, it was, it was...
It was like lots of world-building, and like, it was, it was great!
That was great!
Ha, ha, ha!
No, honestly, it was like, uh, it was like, there was a continuation of it, so, like, uh...
Okay, I'll tell you the plot, the safer work plot.
This girl goes to pick up doll clothes, I think she was very obsessed with dolls.
And, whoop-de-doo, the doll, the doll shop owner is actually a serial killer.
That's the story!
That's the story.
That's, that's the one, I thought that one was really good.
And then, I don't want to give you spoilers, because there's a lot of twists and turns in that one,
and I think it's very enjoyable if you kind of read it as like, like a horror,
and I'm just like, yeah, that's good.
That's like the TLDR, literally the TLDR of like, the plot that I like.
We need the numbers, Mercy, I don't know the numbers!
Do you think of it as playing or reading in a, a VN?
Like, mangles or dojins? No.
It's a completely different medium!
Sounds like a 2013 creepypastas plot.
It was, it's much better than how I'm explaining it.
It's much better than how I'm explaining it.
A book club stream sounds neat.
Honestly, it's, it's probably something that's, um,
the shop owner is a harvester, yeah.
How do you feel about fan-made work of Susie novels?
Like, dojinshi?
Uh, doini?
What do you mean?
Like, like, fan-work?
Great.
Fan-work, great!
Ha ha ha!
Like, if, I don't know, like, I read a,
I read a K-On!
I read a K-On one!
It was great!
I think everyone knows it!
I think it's called, like, This Is It or Something?
Everyone seems to know that one.
It's the one where, you know, it's after,
it's after everything and their lives are weird.
Are you in trouble for posting the numbers?
If it's just the numbers, you should be fine.
Stay with me, uh, it's the other route.
It's the other route that I like.
Um, the K-On! one is the one where,
uh, what's her name?
What's her name gets...
What's her name, the main character girl?
Yeah, the one where they're all adults,
and I don't know, that one was very impactful for me.
That one actually changed, like, my view on life.
It's where, like, what's her name became, like, really famous,
and it's kind of like a written, kind of like a biography of it.
A kind of game that would fit you amazingly well.
You know, Slay the Princess?
Yeah, I know Slay the Princess.
I haven't played it, though, yet.
Yui, yeah.
Uh, it literally changed me, because at the end...
Okay, this is spoilers.
Close your ears if you don't want to hear spoilers.
At the end, um...
Azusa doesn't reach what she perceives as her dreams, right?
Right?
And...
But...
She is working at a...
At a music store, and is still within the industry that she wanted to.
And it was kind of like, she said something like, you know,
like, even if I didn't reach my dreams,
I'm still very close to it or something about it,
and that just, like, changed my entire life.
That just changed me.
That just, like, opened a new side, like a new vision for me, I guess.
Like, she still had an impact.
She still was like...
She didn't reach her dreams, but it was very close,
and I was like, that's a pretty fucking powerful message, right?
And that's where I was like,
oh my gosh, I can't believe this, this, like,
this dojin changed my trajectory of, like, how I view, like, goals,
like, goal settings, and, and, like, what is success?
I think it was called, this is it, this is it?
I think it was called, this is it, or this is us, or what is it, what is it, whatever?
Um...
It's like, they had, like, the cover was like,
Yui, I think, was in like a Michael Jackson pose.
That was the one that I was like, oh, I didn't think it would change, you know, the way
I viewed, I viewed, I viewed what goal setting was, yeah, it's the one where like everything
kind of went to shit, right, and they never reached their dreams or anything, and like
goals were like missed and stuff, but like the ending had like a bitter sweetness to
it, and it just changed the way I just viewed like goals and stuff, because it was something
that I was like, oh, you know, like, even if I don't succeed, there's a chance that I
could still be very close to what I wanted.
That was, yeah, that was what changed me.
I liked that one.
I like that, Joe Jinchi, because it was like, I don't know, it was very profound, it was
very profound, it really changed me, it really did change me, like I honestly at that time
when I read it, I was like devastated, I was devastated that I was not going to reach my
dreams.
Several years ago was a different, different goal, right, and I thought, um, I thought
to myself like, you know, the ending was bitter sweet, and I was like, oh, you know, like,
this isn't terrible, like she got through this, yeah.
So I, I really liked it.
I really liked it, because in the end, even though the message was bitter sweet, I know
that like, maybe it's the author's like, not, not everyone's cup of tea, but that was just
something that I was just like, oh, fuck, that's a very powerful message for me.
And I was like, oh, I have never had this experience before.
And I thought, you know, I'm gonna make it, I'm gonna make it.
I was satisfied in knowing that, you know, it's okay to fail.
The story was not very nice, I'm telling you, it's not a very nice story, but like the ending
just made me go, oh, it's actually very bitter sweet.
Oh yeah.
I don't remember all of it, I just remember just, it just changed the way I thought about
things.
It just changed the way I thought about it, that's it.
Like how I would, yeah, just changed, like, because I was punishing myself the time for
not meeting goals.
And then when I read that, I just changed, it just changed everything.
I just was like, even if I don't reach my dreams, like, if I keep pursuing this, I could
be really close, and that might be okay too.
Yeah, that one was good.
I'm tired now so far.
I'm tired now.
I wanna, I wanna rest, because, to tell you the truth, I wanna go back to my anime.
It's not that I'm sick of you, it's just that I'm watching a really good anime right now.
That I'm very interested in, it's on Netflix, it's called Grimm's Variation, it's called
Grimm's Variation, I like it because it's, it's interesting.
I have a feeling that some senpais might like Episode 2, I feel like some senpais might like
Episode 2, and I don't wanna spoil it, because you're gonna be like, they did the thing!
I think it's gonna be very entertaining, since they've all, it's the first episode
of Supercost Cinderella, yeah.
The second episode is Little Red Riding Hood.
It was really enjoyable to watch Little Red Riding Hood, because they have a lot of, I
have a lot of what do you call it, movie references, and I remember Shibi told me some senpais
really like a certain movie, and they make a reference to it, so I think that's gonna
be fun.
That's gonna be fun at least for senpais who watch that episode and be like, oh!
So I think it's funny.
I think it's funny, I was like, I screen shoted it instead of to, to Shibi saying, oh my
gosh!
The thing you told me about, but yeah, um, yeah, I think that's it.
I wanna watch it now, I'm on episode, what episode am I on?
I'm on episode four right now, I'm on episode four, and I want to, there's only six episodes
senpai, there's only six episodes, so I kinda wanna finish it, you know?
Percy is a closet freak, I finished the doll dojin, it was interesting, right?
It's interesting, right?
It was like, senpai, world building, it was like really good world building, and like,
I liked a very solid, did you read the sequel to it?
There's a sequel to it, which I feel like wraps it up nicely.
Project Haruhi blog did a good deconstruction of that K-On Dojin by the way, if they like
get way too into it, I might change my mind about what I view as success, and I don't
want that.
The art style changed quite a bit in the sequel, so I was like, oh, okay, I think they improved
quite a bit, they had the author, yeah, that was good, yeah, I'm trying to think about
it, I'm like, I don't think I'm that freaky, I feel like it's not something I'm into and
it's something that I'm just like, oh, the story was like really good, literally reading
it for the plot, not sarcasm, literally not sarcasm.
Anyways, thank you senpais for joining me today.
I really want to watch that anime though, it's pretty good in my opinion, so I will
see you all again next time.
Did I go over my schedule already?
I went over my schedule already, okay, don't forget to like and subscribe and leave a comment
if you liked the stream.
Thank you for joining me, thank you for the VTubers who have dropped in as well, I see
you, and I'll see you guys again next time.
Thank you for watching, thank you for watching, bye bye.